CHANNEL ISLANDS AGAIN -- AND SO --
THANK YOU AND AND IF YOU COULD
WELL HAVE EVERYBODY WE WOULD
APPRECIATE.
SO WE'LL SEE SO WELCOME TO CAL
STATE CHANNEL ISLANDS HOW MANY
OF YOU HAVE BEEN HERE BEFORE.
OKAY GOOD SO THROUGH MIX WILL
WORST WE'RE DELIGHTED THAT
YOU'RE HERE -- WE ARE THE NEWEST
AND THE FASTEST GROWING --
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
CAMPUS AND WE ARE HONORED TO
ONCE AGAIN -- HOST THIS
COMMITTEE MEETING AND I WOULD
JUST LIKE TO EXPRESS --
PARTICULAR NOTE OF APPRECIATION
TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER -- WHEN I'M
NOT JUST FOR HER EXEMPLARY
LEADERSHIP ON BEHALF OF OUR
COMMUNITY?
ON AS A WHOLE AND THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA BUT ALSO FOR HER
GREAT SUPPORT FOR EXPANDING
ACCESS TO HIGHER EDUCATION.
ON IN SERVICE OF A BRIGHTER
FUTURE FOR THE YOUNG PEOPLE IN
OUR COMMUNITY AND WE REALLY
APPRECIATE THAT.
SHE ACTUALLY PLAYED A VITAL ROLE
IN BRINGING OUR NEWEST DEGREE
PROGRAM HERE TO THE UNIVERSITY
OF MECHATRONICS ENGINEERING --
WHICH IS A SIGNIFICANT WORK
FORCE NEED AND WILL SERVE AS A
WONDERFUL PATHWAY FOR SO MANY OF
OUR STUDENTS. TO REALLY
INCREDIBLE CAREERS.
ON CYBERSECURITY IS IS A TOPIC
THAT IS NEAR AND DEAR TO OUR
HEART HERE AT CAL STATE CHANNEL
ISLANDS ON THE CHAIR OF OUR
COMPUTER SCIENCE PROGRAM DOCTOR
MICHAEL PSALTIS HE COULD NOT BE
HERE TODAY UNFORTUNATELY.
BUT HE SITS ON ASSEMBLY MEMBER --
WINS ADVISORY.
CYBERSECURITY ADVISORY BOARD HE
ALSO SITS ON THE GOVERNOR
CYBERSECURITY TASK FORCE AND THE
SO CAL HIGH TECH TECHNOLOGY TASK
FORCE HE IS IN ADDITION TO THAT
A CYBER WARFARE FELLOW FOR THE
OFFICE OF NAVAL RESEARCH.
AND HE'S ESTABLISH LASTING
RELATIONSHIPS HERE IN THE
COMMUNITY.
THAT REALLY BUILD TECHNOLOGICAL
PROFICIENCY BUT ALSO PROFICIENCY
AROUND THE ISSUES THAT YOU'LL BE
DISCUSSING TODAY -- ONE GREAT
EXAMPLE OF THIS WORK IS
SOMETHING CALLED -- SEEKERS SO
OUR COMPUTER SCIENCE STUDENTS
THEY PARTNERED WITH A LOCAL
BRANCH OF THE FBI ON END OF
INTER COUNTY DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S
OFFICE TO SOLVE THE PROBLEM OF
ATTAINING.
TIMELY FORENSIC EVIDENCE -- FROM
COMPUTERS IN A WAY THAT PREVENTS
EVIDENCE TAMPERING IS REALLY
IMPORTANT ISSUE AND IN ONE MONTH
A BILL SOMETHING CALLED SEEKER
I'M IT'S A PROTOTYPE OF A
DIGITAL FORENSIC CRIME
PREVENTION TOOL THAT ALLOWS LAW
ENFORCEMENT TO COLLECT EVIDENCE
IN A MATTER OF SECONDS.
I HAD THE GREAT PLEASURE OF
WATCHING OUR STUDENTS UNVEILED
THIS TECHNOLOGY SITTING NEXT TO
FORMER VENTURA COUNTY SHERIFF
JEFF DEAN AND HE ALMOST FELL OUT
OF HIS CHAIR WHEN HE REALIZED
HOW MUCH OF HIS OWN LIFE HE HAD
SPENT.
TRYING TO OBTAIN THIS KIND OF
INFORMATION THAT OUR STUDENTS
ARE ACTUALLY ABLE TO SECURE IN A
MATTER OF SECONDS.
AND THAT'S JUST ONE OF THE MANY
EXAMPLES OF WONDERFUL
PARTNERSHIPS THAT WE HAVE WITH
THE COMMUNITY ALL AROUND ISSUES
OF CYBER SECURITY SO THANK YOU
FOR BEING HERE WISHING YOU A
PRODUCTIVE CONVERSATION -- AND
THINK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER WHEN
FOR EVERYTHING YOU DO FOR CAL
STATE CHANNEL ISLANDS WE
APPRECIATE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH DOCTOR BACK
WE REALLY APPRECIATE IT AND WE
DO APPRECIATE YOUR YOUR
FACULTIES INVOLVEMENT ON OUR
ADVISORY.
COMMITTEE MEETING AND THOSE THE
STUDENTS HERE ARE TRULY --
INCREDIBLE.
AHS SO I WOULD LIKE TO WELCOME
ALL OF YOU TO OUR SELECT
COMMITTEE ON CYBERSECURITY OF
MOST OF THESE COMMITTEE MEETINGS
ARE HELD IN SACRAMENTO AND WE
END UP WITH WE HAVE A WHOLE
BUNCH OF US.
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS THAT ARE ABLE --
TO JOIN US -- BUT SINCE WE ARE
DOING THIS IN THE DISTRICTS
BECAUSE THERE ARE SOME SPECIFIC
DISTRICT ISSUES WE WANT -- TO
DISCUSS WE ARE FILMING TODAY AND
WE'RE GOING TO MAKE SURE TO
SHARE THIS WITH THE REST OF THE
COMMITTEE -- WE DO HAVE A
OUTSIDE A NUMBER OF OUTSTANDING
PANEL SO -- I'M REALLY EXCITED
TO HEAR EVERYTHING THAT -- THEY
HAVE TO SAY AND KNOW WHAT WE
REALLY ARE FOCUSES ON ON SMALL
BUSINESSES TODAY AND AND HOW
THEY ARE ABLE TO HOW THEY CAN
BETTER PROTECT THEMSELVES.
CYBERSECURITY IT'S BEEN IN THE
HEADLINES MORE MORE IN THE PAST
FEW YEARS WITH LARGE SCALE
BREACHES OF PERSONAL INFORMATION
TOUCHING MANY OF OUR LIVES.
AND MANY OF US INTRODUCING MORE
CONNECTED DEVICES INTO OUR HOMES
AND REPORT OF RUSSIAN HACKING
INTERFERENCE IN THE TWENTY
SIXTEEN ELECTION.
BUT CYBER SECURITY IS NOT A NEW
ISSUE OF THE IMPORTANCE IT HAS
BEEN A GROWING THREAT TO AS MORE
OF US TO WHAT GOVERNMENTS DO AND
MORE OF WHAT BUSINESSES DO
DEPEND ON COMPUTERS.
AND THE INTERNET TO INCREASE
PRODUCTIVITY.
OVER THE LAST FOUR YEARS OF MY
EFFORTS BOTH IN CALIFORNIA AND
ACROSS THE UNITED STATES WITH
THE NATIONAL CONFERENCE OF STATE
LEGISLATURES.
I'VE SEEN THAT OUR WORK AT THE
STATE LEVEL TO DEFEND AND BECOME
RESILIENT IS BEING CONSISTENTLY
OUTPACED BY HACKERS.
AND NATION STATES FINDING AND
USING VULNERABILITIES TO
UNDERMINE OUR SECURITY.
WITH SO MUCH OF THE CONVERSATION
BEING FOCUS ON HOW GOVERNMENTS
AND LARGE BUSINESSES ARE BEING
IMPACTED.
I BECAME INCREASINGLY CONCERNED
WITH SMALL BUSINESSES THE TRUE.
ECONOMIC ENGINES OF OUR
COMMUNITY.
AS OUR FIRST PANEL WILL DIVE
DEEPER INTO THE CYBER THREATS
THAT ARE BEING EXPLOITED TODAY.
THAT CYBER THREATS THAT ARE
BEING EXPLOITED TODAY DO NOT
DISCRIMINATE ON THE BUSINESS THE
SIZE OF THE BUSINESS ON THEIR
LOCATION OR WHAT PRODUCTS OR
SERVICES ARE BEING OFFERED.
MANY OF THE THREATS ARE BASED ON
VULNERABILITIES IN THE SOFTWARE
THAT IS WIDELY USED BY
BUSINESSES BOTH LARGE AND SMALL.
THOSE SEEKING TO EXPLOIT THOSE
VULNERABILITIES OFTEN DO NOT
KNOW WHO OR WHAT THEIR HACKING
UNTIL THEY ARE SUCCESSFUL.
MANY OF THE HACKERS ARE USING
AUTOMATED TOOLS LITERALLY
COMBING THE OPEN INTERNET FOR
UNPREPARED NETWORKS AND DEVICES.
THE MORE PASSIVE HACKERS DECIDE
WHETHER STEALING THE INFORMATION
FOR IDENTITY THEFT OR HOLDING
THE INFORMATION FOR RANSOM IS
MORE LUCRATIVE OFTEN THEY DO
BOTH.
OTHERS USE THEIR ACCESS TO
INSERT THEMSELVES INTO BUSINESS
TRANSACTIONS DIVERTING FAT FUNDS
OR SENDING A RONIN YES COMMANDS
TO EMPLOYEES.
THOSE OUTCOMES WHILE DISTRESSING
FOR ANY BUSINESS ARE SPECIALLY
HARMFUL FOR SMALL BUSINESSES AND
AND WE OFTEN HEAR THAT SMALL
BUSINESSES.
AFTER CLOSE AS A RESULT OF THE
BIG BREACH.
THE ABILITY TO PAY RANSOM WHICH
IS STRONGLY DISCOURAGED BY NEW
COMPUTERS OR DEVICES OR HIRE
PROFESSIONAL RESPONSE TEAMS IS
PROHIBITIVELY EXPENSIVE AND AS I
SAID OFTEN RESULTS IN THE
CLOSURE OF SMALL BUSINESSES.
IT IS BECOMING CLEAR THAT THE
BEST AND MOST ECONOMICAL
ECONOMICAL PATH FORWARD FOR
SMALL BUSINESSES TO SURVIVE A
CYBER ATTACK IS TO BE PREPARED.
AND PREVENT AS MANY AS POSSIBLE.
AND HAVE AFFORDABLE CONTINGENCY
PLANS FOR THOSE WHO CANNOT
PREVENT.
A REAL WORLD EXAMPLE OF BENJAMIN
FRANKLIN'S WISDOM AN OUNCE OF
PREVENTION IS WORTH A POUND OF
CURE.
AND THAT'S WHY I DECIDED TO HOLD
THIS INFORMATIONAL HEARING ON
CYBERSECURITY FOR SMALL
BUSINESSES AND PROFESSIONALS.
MY HOPE IS THAT THIS HEARING
WILL HELP PUT THE SPOTLIGHT ON
THE ISSUE FOR SMALL BUSINESSES
AND PROFESSIONALS IN CALIFORNIA
TO UNDERSTAND THAT THEY ARE
TARGETS.
ARE SECOND AND THIRD PANELS WILL
HELP US IDENTIFY NEXT STEPS TO
EMPOWER SMALL BUSINESSES BY
DISCUSSING BEST PRACTICES.
IN ADDRESSING THE CYBER THREATS
AND DISCOVERING HOW TO LEVERAGE
EXISTING LINES OF COMMUNICATION
WITHIN SMALL BUSINESSES AND
PROFESSIONAL COMMUNITIES. TO
SHARE THESE BEST PRACTICES
[INAUDIBLE]
OF ALL RIGHT SO WE ARE GOING TO
GO TO OUR FIRST PANEL
[INAUDIBLE]
AND THE WRITING IS REALLY SMALL.
OPENS RIGHT HERE SO I WOULD OF
LIKE TO WELCOME UP.
TONY WILL.
WHO IS THE SENIOR DEPUTY WITH
THE DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S OFFICE
OF VENTURA COUNTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY?
AND CHEMO HILL DRESS AN
INVESTIGATOR WITH VENTURA COUNTY
DA'S OFFICE.
DETECTIVE ROBERT ARTHUR FROM THE
VENTURA COUNTY SHERIFF'S OFFICE.
AND DEBORAH CHIANG GREASY
DEBORAH HERE -- YES AND DEBORAH
IS THE VP OF BUSINESS
DEVELOPMENT AND PUBLIC POLICY
FOR HACKER.
ONE OF SHE WAS UP IN SACRAMENTO
THIS WEEK AND SHE HAS SOME VERY
INTERESTING THINGS TO SAY A
HACKER ONE IS A VULNERABILITY
COORDINATION AND BUG BOUNTY
PLATFORM.
A THIS PANEL IS GOING TO SEEK TO
GATHER INFORMATION ON THE
CURRENT THREAD.
A THREAT TRENDS THAT ARE
TARGETING THE PRIVATE SECTOR
COMPANIES WITH A FOCUS ON SMALL
BUSINESSES.
AND WE'RE VERY EXCITED -- TO
HERE WITH ALL THE PEOPLE HAVE TO
SAY SO WELCOME AND THANK YOU
AGAIN FOR TAKING PART IN.
OUR SELECT.
THANK YOU.
I THINK WHERE TO START WITH TONY
RIGHT OKAY GOOD MORNING --
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD YOU.
TO PICTURE HYPOTHETICAL WHERE A
BUSINESS TRANSACTION IS UNDER
WAY [INAUDIBLE]
AND A THE ONE PROFESSIONAL IS
SEEKING TO PURCHASE ASSETS FROM
ANOTHER PROFESSIONAL ON IT KEEP
IN MIND THIS IS IN THE SMALL
BUSINESS CONTEXT.
SO IF THE PURCHASER YET OF A
SELLER.
SO THE PURCHASER HAS AN AGENT
THAT WORKS IN THE PURCHASERS
OFFICE AND THIS.
TRANSACTION IS AN ESCROW.
AND AS IT IS NEARING THE END OF
THE ESCROW PROCESS.
THE PURCHASER THE PURCHASING
AGENT KNOWS THAT IT'S ALMOST
TIME TO WIRE SIGNIFICANT AMOUNTS
OF MONEY INTO THE SELLERS BANK
ACCOUNT.
SO THIS -- THIS PURCHASING AGENT
IS AWARE THAT THERE ARE
SIGNIFICANT THREATS AROUND
CYBERSECURITY -- THIS THIS IS
PROFESSIONAL THIS AGENT HAS
OBTAINED AT THE BEGINNING OF THE
TRANSACTION -- THE ACCOUNT
NUMBERS THAT ARE NOT GOING TO BE
USED TO ACCOMPLISH THIS WIRE
TRANSFER OF SIGNIFICANT FUNDS
FROM.
HER EMPLOYER INTO THE SELLER'S
ACCOUNT.
SO AT THE TIME THAT THIS THESE
FUNDS ARE DUE TO BE TRANSFERRED.
UP SHE GOES TO EXECUTE THE
TRANSACTION BUT IT'S NOT GOING
THROUGH.
SO SHE DOES WHAT SHE'S BEEN
TRAINED TO DO SHOULD PICK UP THE
PHONE AND SHE CALLS THE SELLER'S
AGENT.
AND SHE SAYS TO THE SELLER'S
AGENT HEY I'M TRYING TO WIRE.
YOUR ROUGHLY HALF A MILLION
DOLLARS INTO THIS BANK ACCOUNT
SO WE CAN COMPLETE THIS
TRANSACTION AND CONCLUDE ESCROW.
AND SO THE SELLER'S AGENT LOOKS
AT THE WIRING INSTRUCTIONS THAT
WERE PROVIDED AT THE BEGINNING
OF THE TRANSACTION.
AND REALIZES THAT THERE WAS A
TYPO AND THAT ONE OF THE ACCOUNT
ONE OF THE DIGITS OF THE ACCOUNT
NUMBER IS WRONG.
SO TELEPHONICALLY THIS A
SELLER'S AGENT TELLS THE
PURCHASERS AGENT.
I'M GOING TO SEND YOU AN EMAIL
WITH THE CORRECT ACCOUNT
INSTRUCTIONS WITH THE CORRECT
ACCOUNT NUMBER.
AND THAT HAPPENS.
AND SO THE CELL THE PURCHASERS
AGENT OPENS UP HER EMAIL SPECIES
OKAY HERE'S NEW WIRING
INSTRUCTIONS WITH AN ACCOUNT
NUMBER.
HOWEVER WITHIN SECONDS OF
RECEIVING THAT EMAIL.
THE PURCHASERS AGENT RECEIVES A
SECOND EMAIL SEC I'M SORRY I
MADE A MISTAKE.
DISREGARD THAT FIRST EMAIL USE
THE ACCOUNT NUMBER IN THIS
SECOND EMAIL.
AND KEEP IN MIND THE PURCHASERS
AGENT JUST GOT OFF THE PHONE
WITH THE SELLER'S AGENT.
AND SO SHE SAYS OKAY MAKES SENSE
AND SHE WIRES.
JUST OVER HALF A MILLION DOLLARS
OUT OF HER EMPLOYERS ACCOUNT
INTO WHAT SHE BELIEVES TO BE THE
SELLER'S ACCOUNT.
OF COURSE.
WE ALL KNOW HOW THE STORY ENDS.
THAT WAS NOT THE LEGITIMATE
ACCOUNT AND JUST OVER HALF A
MILLION DOLLARS HAS JUST BEEN
SENT SOMEWHERE INTO THE CYBER.
YOU KNOW TO THE CYBER NETWORK.
AND THOSE FUNDS ARE LARGELY
COULD BE.
UNOBTAINABLE THEY'RE NOT COMING
BACK SO THE QUESTION THAT ALL OF
US IN THIS ROOM WOULD BE ASKING
AS WELL.
HOW DID THE CROOK NOTICE SENT?
THIS SECOND EMAIL SO QUICKLY IF
THIS IS HOW DID THIS CROOKED
THIS IMMACULATE TIMING.
AND THE ANSWER IS REAL TIME
SURVEILLANCE.
THAT IS THE LEVEL OF
SOPHISTICATION THAT WE'RE SEEING
WITH CYBER CRIMINALS.
THE IT'S BELIEVED THAT THE THAT
THE CRIMINAL HAD INSTALLED
MALWARE EITHER A TROJAN.
OR SOME SORT OF REAL TIME
SURVEILLANCE SOFTWARE TO ONE BE
AWARE THAT THIS TRANSACTION WAS
OCCURRING. TO TO KNOW ALL THAT
FROM THIS THAT THIS FIRST EMAIL
CAME IN AND ACTION NEED TO BE
TAKEN IMMEDIATELY.
AND THE ONLY WAY THAT COULD BE
WHICH IS REAL TIME SURVEILLANCE
AND WHAT THIS AND UNFORTUNATELY
OF COURSE THIS IS A REAL CASE
AND THOSE FUNDS WERE TRANSFERRED
OUT.
AND WHAT IT REPRESENTS IS THE
INCREASING AND ASTOUNDING --
SOPHISTICATION OF CYBER
CRIMINALS.
NOW.
THAT IS TYPICALLY CALLED
DESCAMPS CALLED BUSINESS EMAIL
COMPROMISE AND BUSINESS EMAIL
COMPROMISES WHEN A YOU KNOW IS
WHAT IT CRIMINAL HAS PENETRATED
SOMEONE'S NETWORK -- TYPICALLY
IT IS.
IT'S OUR SOME SORT OF
PROFESSIONAL THEY'RE AWARE THAT
THEIR TRANSACTION IS TAKING
PLACE THEY'RE AWARE THAT THEY
NEED TO BE VERY VERY PERFECT ON
THEIR TIMING. TO HAVE WIRES THAT
HAD TO HAVE THE FUNDS WIRED TO
THEM.
THAT SORT OF COMPROMISE IN TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN COST THE
TAXPAYERS OF THIS STATE OVER
FORTY TWO MILLION DOLLARS.
AND HALF OF THAT FLOWS FORTY TWO
MILLION DOLLARS ARE BELIEVED TO
HAVE -- TARGETED A REAL ESTATE
CONSUMERS JUST LIKE ME IN YOU
NORMAL PEOPLE TRYING TO BUY
PROPERTY.
AND THEY LOSE THEIR MONEY TO
LIFESAVING SEARCHES WIRED OUT --
THE ANOTHER CASE THAT WAS WORK
BY THE DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S
OFFICE INVOLVED -- ANOTHER
SCAMPER SIMILAR TO THE FIRST
CAMP THAT I TALKED ABOUT -- BUT
AFTER THE FUNDS WERE WIRED OUT --
KEEP THE INVESTIGATOR HILDRETH
WE'LL TALK ABOUT THIS CASE A
LITTLE BIT MORE BUT THE FUNDS
WERE WIRED OUT INTO THAT OUT OF
STATE BANK ACCOUNT -- THE PERSON
THAT RECEIVE THOSE FUNDS THEN
CONVERTED THOSE FUNDS INTO A
CASHIER'S CHECKS NOT ONE BUT TWO
CASHIERS CHECKS THAT WERE THEN
PLACED INTO STANDARD US MAIL
ACTUALLY TAKE A BACK FED EX.
AND THEN SENT TO TWO DIFFERENT
DESTINATIONS ELSEWHERE IN THE
UNITED STATES.
AND ONE THOSE -- PACKAGES
ARRIVED AT THEIR DESTINATIONS
THOSE DESTINATIONS WERE BIG
POINT EXCHANGES.
SO THE CRIMINAL WAS IN THE
PROCESS LITERALLY UP TAKING.
A CRIMINAL PROCEEDS THAT THEY
HAD STOLEN FROM A SUCCESSFUL
BUSINESS EMAIL COMPROMISE CAM
AND THEN WE'RE LOOKING TO
LAUNDER THAT MONEY FROM U. S.
CURRENCY INTER CRYPTOCURRENCY
WHERE IT WOULD THEN ZERO
DISAPPEAR INTO THE CRYPTO
CURRENCY MARKETS.
WHICH ARE NOT UNTRACEABLE BUT
IT'S EXCEEDINGLY DIFFICULT TO
TRACE THAT MONEY ONCE IT MOVES
INTO THE CRYPTO CURRENCY ROUND
[INAUDIBLE]
SO.
THE AS AS YOU ARE AWARE OF THIS
IS JUST COULD SIGNIFICANT
PROBLEM NOT JUST IN CALIFORNIA
BUT ACROSS THE UNITED STATES --
WORLDWIDE IT'S BILLIONS AND
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS -- THERE IS
NOT A FIRM TECHNOLOGY FIX FOR
THIS PROBLEM -- OR I WORK IN THE
REAL ESTATE FRAUD UNIT I WORK
AND I JUST RETURNING GREG TITANS
REAL ESTATE FRAUD UNIT -- WE ARE
ONE OF THE FEW UP COUNTIES IN
THE STATE THAT HAS A DEDICATED
REAL ESTATE FRAUD UNIT AND WE
ARE HERE TO INVESTIGATE AND
PROSECUTE THESE TYPES OF CRIMES.
AS PART OF MY MANDATE A TO
SPREAD AWARENESS OF BUSINESS
EMAIL COMPROMISE SCAMS I TALKED
TO A LOT OF REALTORS.
AND WE TALKED TO REALTORS
BECAUSE AS I SAID 50% OF BC
SCAMS IN THIS STATE TARGET.
CONSUMERS INVOLVED IN REAL
ESTATE TRANSACTIONS.
AND LAW ENFORCEMENT BELIEVES
THAT THE THE MOST COMMON POINT
OF PENETRATION THE BREACH FOR
REAL ESTATE RELATED BUSINESS
EMAIL COMPROMISE SCAMS ARE WITH
REAL ESTATE PROFESSIONALS.
AGENTS BROKERS.
AND THAT IS A SIGNIFICANT ISSUE.
THAT'S A SIGNIFICANT CHALLENGE
BECAUSE AS YOU ARE AWARE -- THE
VAST MAJORITY OF REAL ESTATE
PROFESSIONALS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA OUR TEN NINETY NINE
EMPLOYEES -- BROKERS AGENTS.
AND THE PROBLEM WITH THAT THE
TECHNOLOGICAL PROBLEMS AT THAT
PRESENTS FOR TACKLING BUSINESS
EMAIL COMPROMISES THAT THEY DO
NOT HAVE CENTRALIZED IT SUPPORT.
THERE'S NO CENTRALIZED.
COMPUTER PROFESSIONALS THAT ARE
LOCKING DOWN THEIR NETWORKS
MAKING SURE THAT THE OPERATING
SYSTEMS ARE PATCHED THAT THEY
HAVE TO DO IS TO LATEST UP YOU
KNOW MALWARE THAT THEIR
FIREWALLS ARE PATCHED.
THAT THEY ARE RUNNING THE MOST
CURRENT BROWSERS WHATEVER THEY
USE WHETHER IT'S INTERNET
EXPLORER OR GOOGLE CHROME --
BECAUSE THAT'S HOW CRIMINALS OR
EXT TAKING ADVANTAGE BEEN.
PERFORMING THESE BREACHES IS BY
GOING INTO ON PACKED SYSTEMS.
SO IT CREATES A SIGNIFICANT
CHALLENGE BECAUSE NOT ALL REAL
ESTATE AGENTS ARE
TECHNOLOGICALLY SAVVY.
I WAS VERY STRUCK WHEN I GAVE A
PRESENTATION A FEW MONTHS AGO
AND KEEP IN MIND REAL ESTATE
PROFESSIONALS COME FROM ALL
WALKS OF LIFE ALL BACKGROUND
SUMMER TECHNOLOGY.
A TECHNOLOGICALLY SAVVY MANY OR
NOT.
AND AN OLDER REAL ESTATE AGENT
RAISED HER HAND SHE SAID HOW MY
SUPPOSED -- TO MAKE SURE THAT MY
OPERATING SYSTEMS UP TO STOP ON
MY TABLET ON MY COMPUTER THAT
I'M RUNNING UP YOU KNOW.
TECHNOLOGY SECURITY SOFTWARE ON
MY PHONE ONE I STILL HAVE TO
CALL MY GRANDSON TO ASK HIM TO
COME OVER TO MY HOUSE TO ADD.
A NEW CONTACT TO MY PHONE.
AND THAT REALLY UNDERSCORES THE
NATURE OF THE PROBLEM IS.
CYBER THIEVES ARE
EXTRAORDINARILY SOPHISTICATED
AND THEY ARE TAKING ADVANTAGE OF
AFFORDABLE POPULATION THAT IS
TYPICALLY NOT TECHNOLOGICALLY
SOPHISTICATED.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
WHO ARE WE GOING TO HAVE?
I CAN GO NEXT.
I HOPE THAT THE RADIO.
YES -- HI MY NAME'S CHEMO
HILDRETH -- I'M A COP SO I NEED
SOME PICTURES TONY'S OF VERY
DEEP INTO THIS VERY
KNOWLEDGEABLE -- I FOUND A LOT
OF TIMES PEOPLE ARE NOT AS AWARE
OF BUSINESS EMAIL COMPROMISE SO
IF THIS IS OUR MEDIA ALIVE I
APOLOGIZE BUT IT SEEMS TO BE
HELPFUL -- QUICKLY ABOUT ME I
START OUT OF MOLD STARTED
RUNNING KING RIGHTS SHIRTS
APARTMENT -- NINE ELEVEN
HAPPENED I GOT A LOT OF INDUSTRY
CERTS -- IN TECHNOLOGY -- TWENTY
FIFTEEN I MOVED OUT HERE I NOW
WORK FOR THE VENTURA COUNTY DA'S
OFFICE AND I'M ON F. B. I. CYBER
TASK FORCE.
ALL THESE THINGS I TALK ABOUT
ARE MY OWN OPINION NOT THAT OF
THE U. S. GOVERNMENT OR JACQUI
IRWIN OR ANY OTHER GOVERNMENT
AGENCY.
SO BAD JOKES AROUND ME.
AND GOOD ONES -- TONY GOT SPOKE
ABOUT A COUPLE OF THESE -- LOCAL
VICTIMS.
I'LL JUST TOUCH ON IT MY DAD WAS
BUYING HIS SON HIS FIRST
BUSINESS WITH HIS LIFE SAVINGS --
AND HE GOT HIT BY ONE OF THESE
BUSINESS EMAIL COMPROMISE ESCROW
WIRES THAT TONY MENTIONED AND
EVERYTHING'S GONE.
NO INSURANCE NOTHING COVERS THAT
MONEY'S GONE.
THIS ONE HAD A HAPPY ENDING
THANKS THE DA'S OFFICE -- VERY
GOOD PROSECUTOR WHO'S VERY CLOSE
TO TONY HIS WIFE -- KAREN WALLED
I WAS ABLE TO GET ALL THE MONEY
BACK WELL MINE IS SIX THOUSAND
DOLLARS.
ANOTHER ONE A LOCAL BUSINESSES
TRYING TO EXPAND SIX HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLAR WIRE -- POOF
SAME THING GONE.
IT WASN'T SO LUCKY IN THAT CASE.
SO WHAT ARE THE STATS LOOKING
LIKE WILL LIKELY THE INTERNET
CRIME CENTER -- JUST CAME OUT
WITH THEIR TWENTY EIGHTEEN STATS
A FEW DAYS AGO EVEN THOUGH WE'RE
HALFWAY THROUGH.
TWENTY NINETEEN AND CALIFORNIA
LEADS THE WAY WE'RE WINNING AND
WE DON'T MEAN WINNING AS FAR AS
LAW ENFORCEMENT WINNING.
OR ANYTHING ELSE THE BAD GUYS
ARE WINNING WE HAVE FORTY NINE
THOUSAND PEOPLE FILED CYBER
CRIMES -- TO THIS SITE SO
PROBABLY TRIPLE THAT IT WAS
BRIGHT CLOSE TO THE REAL NUMBER.
CALIFORNIA'S ALSO WINNING IN OUR
LOSSES FOUR HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS LAST YEAR.
CYBER CRIMES.
AND I PUT THIS NUMBER IN HERE
JUST BECAUSE THE NEXT PERSON
SPEAKS AND BE MY FRIEND A DEPUTY
BOBBY ARTHUR'S IN PART TALK
ABOUT MALL WHERE I JUST WANT TO
SHOW YOU HOW PALTRY THAT AMOUNT
IS COMPARED TO WHAT I'M TALKING
ABOUT WHICH IS BUSINESS EMAIL
COMPROMISE SO.
THE NUMBER ONE LEADS THE WAY
SOMETHING MOST PEOPLE HAVEN'T
HEARD ABOUT BUSINESS EMAIL
COMPROMISE WITH THE LOSS OF ONE
POINT TWO BILLION DOLLARS
[INAUDIBLE]
REAL MONEY.
AND IT'S ATTACKING SMALL MEDIUM
SIZE BUSINESSES WHY BECAUSE
THAT'S WHERE THE MONEY IS AND IT
CAN BE DEVASTATING.
THIS DATA -- MR WHEN REFERRED TO
A MINUTE AGO 60% OF SMALL AND
MEDIUM SIZED BUSINESSES THAT ARE
HIT.
ARE CLOSED WITH A MAJOR PREACHER
CLOSE SIX MONTHS LATER.
SO YOU CAN HAVE A FAMILY
BUSINESS IN IN BUSINESS FOR
GENERATIONS AND IT'S GONE.
AND THIS IS NOT JUST TV THIS IS
REAL WE HAVE PEOPLE CALLING THE
FBI OFFICE IN TWO YEARS --
THEY'VE LOST THE GENERATIONAL
BUSINESS OR THEY'VE LOST ALL THE
MONEY THAT WAS GOING TO GO TO
BUY A HOME.
IT CETERA.
THE REAL PROBLEM SO I'M GONNA
TALK BRIEFLY ABOUT BUSINESS
EMAIL COMPROMISED IN ITS
SIMPLEST FORM IT'S SOMEONE
PRETENDING TO BE THE CEO AT YOUR
COMPANY -- ROOM WRITING AN EMAIL
AS IF THEY ARE THE CEO TO
SOMEONE IN ACCOUNTS PAYABLE FOR
LET'S SAY YOU KNOW TO BUY
MILLION DOLLAR -- NEW OFFICE
WELL THE ACCOUNTS PAYABLE PERSON
WANTING TO GET THERE CHRISTMAS
BONUS CHECK AND MAKE THE BOSS
HAPPY WILL DO IT WITHOUT EVER
TALKING TO THE BOSS JUST BASED
ON AN EMAIL.
NOW BUSINESS EMAIL COMPROMISE A
LOT OF TIMES ARE SUSPECTS ARE
OVERSEAS AND WE CAN'T GET THEM
OR IT'S VERY DIFFICULT TO GET
THEM BUT WHAT IS LOCAL IS WHAT
WE CALL THE MONEY BILL SOMEBODY
HAS TO HAVE A REAL BUSINESS
ACCOUNT A REAL BANKING ACCOUNT.
THESE ARE MONEY MANY LAUNDERS WE
CALL MONEY BILLS -- AND THE
MONEY MEALS.
A LOT OF TIMES THEMSELVES THIS
GETS REALLY TRICKY AND I THINK
TONY WENT OVER A LOT OF THIS BUT
IT'S VERY CONFUSING SO I LIKE
PICTURES SO BEAR WITH ME.
SO A LOT OF TIMES THE PERSON
WITH THE BANK ACCOUNT IS A
VICTIM OF ROMANCE CAM THEMSELF.
SO SOMEBODY LIKE THIS LADY AN
ACTUAL VENTURE A PERSON OF COLOR
JULIET CYBER JULIET IS DATING
SOMEONE ONLINE FOR A COUPLE
YEARS ME TO MY MATCH DOT COM
AFTER HER HUSBAND DIED -- THERE
THIS GUY'S TELLING HER
EVERYTHING SHE WANTS TO HEAR SHE
HAD A LITTLE FOOT SURGERY HE
SENDS HER FLOWERS TEDDY BEARS.
HE TALKS TO WERE SEVERAL TIMES A
DAY MUCH BETTER THAN I AM WITH
MY WIFE THAT'S MY JOKE BUT SADLY
IT'S TRUE -- AND IN THE END --
ANYBODY WANT TO GUESS HOW MUCH
MONEY THIS LADY WAS OUT IN A TWO
YEAR RELATIONSHIP. THREE HUNDRED
EIGHTY THREE THOUSAND DOLLARS.
DOES ANYONE WANT TO GUESS -- HER
LEVEL OF EDUCATION [INAUDIBLE]
PHD.
SO OF SOME OF THAT PHD.
BEFORE I STARTED INVESTIGATING
THIS I THOUGHT THESE PEOPLE WERE
ALL SUCKERS THEY'RE NOT.
THESE CRIMES ARE VERY --
INVOLVED -- AND WORST OF ALL SHE
WASN'T TALKING TO THAT MAN SHE
WAS TALKING TO MY SUSPECT IN
CHICAGO.
SO WHO KNOWS BETTER HOW TO TALK
TO A LADY THAT ANOTHER WOMAN HIS
MEN WE DON'T KNOW WHAT WE'RE
DOING IN THAT REALM BUT REMEMBER
IT'S MOTHER'S DAY ON SUNDAY.
THAT WAS A PUBLIC SERVICE
ANNOUNCEMENT FOR MEN AND SO HOW
INTRICATE ARE THESE -- LÀ I GO
GIVE YOU QUICKLY TO HELP
UNDERSTAND HOW THIS WORKS HOW
THE BAD GUY -- MANIPULATES
PEOPLE AND I I KEEP REFERRING TO
THE VICTIM OF ROMANCE CAM AS A
WOMAN -- THERE ARE A LOT OF MEN
VICTIMS TOO BUT THEIR CRIMES ARE
NOT NEARLY AS INTERESTING
BECAUSE ALL THE WOMAN HAS TO DO
IS SEND SOME TOPLESS PHOTOS AND
THEY GOT HIM HOOK LINE AND
SINKER.
WHERE IS THE THE WOMEN WHO ARE
THE VICTIMS HAVE TO BE -- WOULD
A LITTLE MORE SO SO THEY'LL MEET
HIM ON LIKE MATCH DOT COM THE
VERY QUICKLY TELLEM.
LET'S MOVE TO ANOTHER -- ANOTHER
METHOD OF COMMUNICATION SOME
SORT OF CHATTING -- AND THIS IS
WHAT'S CALLED CAT FISHING YOU'VE
PROBABLY HEARD OF ITS TWENTY
TWENTY SIXTY MINUTES -- AND THE
BAD GUY WILL HAVE PICKED SOME
GOOD LOOKING DUDES OFF.
OFF THE INTERNET WHO POST A LOT
THAT'S WHY A LOT OF TIMES THE
PICTURES ARE MILITARY GUYS
BECAUSE THEIR OVERSEAS AND
THEY'RE SENDING VIDEO AND SO
FORTH BACK TO THEIR FAMILIES
BACK HOME.
SO THEY JUST NEED A FOLDER OF
THEIR GUY IN A LOT OF DIFFERENT
POSES SO THEY CAN KEEP SENDING
IT TO THE POOR VICTIM.
AND THEN IF THE GUY THEIR LOVER
OF THEIR CYBER ROMEO SUPPOSEDLY
FROM HOUSTON TEXAS.
THEY'LL CALL THE VICTIM FROM
HOUSTON TEXAS PHONE NUMBER HOW
DO THEY DO THAT THESE ARE FREE
PHONES MOVING OUT I ALWAYS SAY
IF YOU DON'T KNOW HOW TO DO IT --
ASK YOUR TEENAGE CHILD.
IT'S VERY EASY -- THEY'LL SET UP
FAKE BANK WEB PAGES THIS IS A
FAKE WHAT WEB PAGE OF CHARTER
STANDARD CHARTERED BANK
EVERYTHING LOOK REAL.
SOMETIMES YOU CATCH SOME
SPELLING ERRORS YOU CAN'T SEE IT
THAT'S TOO SMALL THERE BUT AND
THEY'LL HAVE THE VICTIM IN MY
ONE CASE THE VICTIM WAS TOLD TO
LOG INTO THE SUSPECTS WEB PAGE.
SHE DID THE SUSPECT TRUSTED HER
ENOUGH TO GIVE HER HIS USERNAME
AND PASSWORD FOR THE WEB PAGE.
THE WEBPAGE FAKE BY THE WAY
RIGHT SO SHE LOGS IN AND SHE
SEES ALL MY GOD NOT ONLY IS THIS
GUY.
THIS HOT BRAZILIAN SIX WITH TWO
WASHBOARD ABS.
BUT WHEN SHE LOGGED INTO HIS
ACCOUNT HE HAS THREE MILLION
POUNDS STERLING SITTING THERE.
SO NOW THEY GOT THE VICTIM HOOK
LINE AND SINKER BECAUSE SHE'S
ALREADY IN LOVE.
AND THERE'S THE GREED ELEMENT
IT'S A IT'S A COMBINATION THAT
CAN'T BE BROKEN -- I OFTEN TO
ASK WELL HOW DO YOU HOW DO YOU
TALK TO THESE PEOPLE I MEAN ARE
YOU THERE SAY WE'RE WE'RE LIVE
CHATTING I SAID WELL WHEN YOU'RE
TALKING TO HIM OUR THEIR MOUTHS
MOVING OUR OUR HOW ARE THE BAD
GUYS DOING IT WHY FOUND
UNIVERSITY OF WASHINGTON.
HAD PUT TOGETHER -- A SOFTWARE.
ON OUR LEFT -- IT'S A PRESIDENT
OF BROCCO BOMB ON THE VIEW
THAT'S REAL ON OUR RIGHT IT'S UP
PRESIDENT OBAMA -- WITH A
BASICALLY A FAKE MOUTH AND THE
BAD GUYS CAN.
BE TALKING TO A VICTIM ONLINE
AND HAVE THAT -- VIDEO GOING AND
HIS MOUTH TO MOVE ACCORDING TO
WHAT THEY'RE SAYING IN REAL TIME.
SO THAT'S OUT HOW INTRICATE
THEY'RE BECOMING HOMELESS I
DON'T KNOW IF THIS'LL.
YOU GOT AUDIO.
WE HAVE ALREADY.
WAS VERY GOOD -- WE HAD AUDIO WE
TESTED WITH THIS IS HOW IT
ALWAYS GOES -- THEY THEY'VE DONE
IT FOR A BUNCH OF VARIOUS --
WORLD LEADERS JUST SAID TO THE
AS A PROOF OF CONCEPT.
BUT HIS MOUTH BASICALLY WE CAN
SEE FROM LEFT AND RIGHT HIS
MOUTH IS MOVING THE SAME IN BOTH
AND IT'S EASY TO TRICK SOMEBODY
WITH THIS.
I GOT A COUPLE MORE IDEAS IF YOU
CAN.
HE PUT THE OLD ONE BACK IN -- SO
THAT'S WHAT ONE EMAIL THE OTHER
STYLE.
THE OTHER ONE IS -- WORK AT HOME --
MONEY BILLS A LOT OF COLLEGE
STUDENTS GET HIT WITH THESE --
BECAUSE THEY TRY TO MAKE A
LITTLE EXTRA MONEY AND THEY'LL
STILL FILL OUT A JOB APPLICATION
THEY'LL DO A BACKGROUND CHECK
SURPRISINGLY THEY'LL PASS.
A LOT OF PEOPLE LEISURE VILLAGE
GET THIS ONE TO TRYING ON A
FIXED INCOME TRYING TO MAKE SOME
EXTRA MONEY AND ALL THEY'RE
DOING IS RECEIVING MONEY AND AND
WIRING IT OUT SOMEWHERE ELSE IN
THERE JUST.
LAUNDERING STOLEN MONEY BUT THEY
HAVE NO IDEA THEY THINK THEY'RE
DOING A LEGITIMATE BUSINESS.
AND SO I EXPLAIN BOTH OF THOSE
TO COME TO THIS SLIDE.
I HAD ONE WORK AT HOME -- VICTIM
IN HAWAII SENT THREE HUNDRED
NINETEEN THOUSAND DOLLARS TO A
ROMANCE CAM VICTIM IN CAMARILLO
CALIFORNIA WHO WAS TOLD BY HER
CYBER BOYFRIEND TO WIRED TO
THREE DIFFERENT PLACES IN
WISCONSIN.
SO HOW DO WE GET THAT MONEY BACK
THIS IS WHERE WE NEED SOME FIXES
BECAUSE THAT'S LIKE PUTTING
TOOTHPASTE BACK IN A TWO THE
MONEY'S ALL OVER THE PLACE IT'S
CASH.
AND IT MOVES FAST.
AND THIS IS ONLY GOING UP THIS
IS A TREND MICRO'S THAT I FOUND --
SUPPOSED TO HIT NINE BILLION IN
TWENTY EIGHTEEN FBI STATS I READ
SAID IT HIT TWELVE BILLION --
THEY'RE HITTING MAJOR.
THE MAJOR COMPANIES ONE UBIQUITY
UP IN THE BAY AREA GOT HIT IN
ONE OF THESE FOR FORTY SIX
MILLION DOLLARS.
OTHER HITTING UNIVERSITIES THE
HEADING OUR INVESTMENTS --
THEY'RE GOING AFTER THE COURT
SYSTEMS -- I HAVE A REAL ESTATE
ABOUT FIVE MINUTE LONG VIDEO
WHICH I GUESS GIVEN JUST TALK
ALL THE ANSWERS IF YOU HAVE A
LOT OF AUDIO WE HAVE AUDIO LET'S
SEE -- OKAY.
THIS DESCRIBES REAL STAY BCI USE
REALISTIC IS THAT AFFECTS ALL OF
US BECAUSE WE ALL HAVE HOMES BY
HOME SELL HOMES IS FANTASTIC
VIDEO [INAUDIBLE]
THE YOU HEAR.
I HAVEN'T SEEN -- MESSAGE.
I'M NOT SURE COMPLETELY
UNDERSTAND.
HE'S GONE ALL OF IT EVERYTHING
WE WORK HARDER.
FOR THIS IS A TWO THOUSAND TO
JUST DISAPPEAR.
THERE MUST BE SOME KIND OF THE
STATE THERE'S NO MISTAKE.
WHO -- I REALLY STAGE
[INAUDIBLE]
LAWLER.
MY HOLES AND HE HAS FOR
COMPANIES.
TO TIMES WHEN FROM ON THE SENATE
RACE TASK FORCE.
THE ESCROW COMPANY RUNNING AND
TO SEE THAT AND I NEED TO GET AS
MUCH INFORMATION FROM THE
ABSOLUTELY ANYTHING WE CAN DO.
FOR STARTERS.
I GOT AN EMAIL REQUESTING TO
CHANGE THE WIRING INSTRUCTIONS
FROM YOUR YEAH I GOT.
ONE OF THESE AGO FROM A REAL
ESTATE AGENT.
THIS IS THE BEST NUMBER YEAH.
AND I HAVE.
THEY CAN DO THAT.
ACTUALLY SEND AN EMAIL FROM HIS
ACCOUNT IT'S A FOUR STEP PROCESS
THAT I CAN WALK YOU THROUGH IT.
IT IS NUMBER ONE THEY REFUSE
SOMETHING CALLED AN EMAIL
EXTRACTOR SOFTWARE YOU CAN BUY
ON THE INTERNET.
THAT ENABLES THEM TO COLLECT
EMAIL ADDRESSES FOR THOUSANDS OF
PEOPLE WORKING IN A PARTICULAR
INDUSTRY.
IN THIS CASE THE REAL.
ESTATE.
AGENTS BROKERS ESCROW OFFICER.
ANYBODY WITH THE REAL ESTATE
RELATED EXTENSION.
STEP.
INVOLVES THE HACKERS IN A
FIFTEEN HOUR TWO THOUSAND
ADDRESSES THEY JUST HARVESTED.
ARE.
THE PEOPLE THAT THE ONLY NUMBER
CLICKING ON A LINK OR OPENING
AND AND SO WE NEED. TO TAKE
THEIR NAMES.
THAT SOUNDS THREE RESEARCH --
LISTING ADDRESSES SALES PRICES
TO ROMANCE S. TITLE COMPANY
NAMES EVEN.
SOPHISTICATED AND THEN THAT
[INAUDIBLE]
SO [INAUDIBLE] NINE NINE
QUESTION JUST CENTER.
OR WONDER FIRMS TO A DIFFERENT
ACCOUNT.
IN.
MUST BE TREATED AS SUSPICIOUS
AND MUST BE FOLLOWED UP WITH A
PHONE CALL TO VERIFY IT'S
AUTHENTICITY. NINE COURTESY TO
CONTACT YOUR LENDER.
RECALL.
IT'S A LONG SHOT SIX SEVEN DAYS.
IT'S WORKING.
WELL IS THERE ANYTHING ELSE WE
SHOULD BE DOING [INAUDIBLE]
IMMEDIATELY -- THROUGH BECAUSE
IT SUMS UP A VERY DIFFICULT --
THING TO UNDERSTAND EASILY SO
BASICALLY IT'S A TONY'S SPOKE OF
A LOT OF SOME WAYS THEY GET OUR
INFORMATION BUT THERE'S MANY
WAYS -- THE BAD GUYS LET'S SAY
WANT TO TARGET -- BUSINESSES HE
CAN BY ONE POINT THREE MILLION
FOR EIGHTY FOUR DOLLARS AS LEADS
IN THIS IS NOT DARK WEB STUFF
THIS IS YOU KNOW LEGITIMATE HE
CAN BUY LEADS AND THAT'S HIS
LIST OF PEOPLE TO SEND FISHING
EMAILS -- TO YOU CAN PICK ALL
THE REALTORS AND LA ORANGE
COUNTY FOR ELEVEN BUCKS YOU GET
TEN THOUSAND OF THEM SOMEONE'S
GOING TO BE FISH SUCCESSFULLY
AND THEN THE BAG I CAN -- BY ONE
OF THESE KIDS TWENTY FIVE BUCKS
IF YOU WANT -- YOU KNOW HELP
TECH SUPPORT IS FORTY FIVE
DOLLARS AND IT HAS ALL THE STUFF
YOU NEED -- TO DO THE FISHING --
TO GATHER THE INFORMATION TO
VICTIMIZE PEOPLE.
AND THEN HE SENDS OUT A EMAIL
LIKE THIS WHICH OF FISHING EMAIL
WHERE THE A REALTOR WILL ENTER
THEIR EMAIL AND PASSWORD OR THE
ESCROW PERSON WHOEVER -- AND AND
HOW MANY PEOPLE BOUGHT A HOUSE
AND USE DOCUSIGN.
AND YOU SEE THAT LITTLE
THUMBNAIL BUT YOU CAN'T QUITE
SEE RIGHT SO THEN YOU SO THIS IS --
AND ANOTHER ONE WE SEEN WHERE
THEN YOU CLICK ON THE THUMBNAIL
THINK YOU'RE GONNA SEE A
DOCUSIGN AND THEY WANT YOU TO
SIGN IN.
HERE AND THEN THEY HAVE PROBLEMS
WITH THE SPELLING SO.
THEY DON'T GET THE SPELLING
RIGHT AND IT'S ACTUALLY GOING TO
THIS EMAIL THIS -- U. R. L. NOT
TO DOCUSIGN.
AND THEN YOU GET THIS VERY
REALISTIC LOOKING SIGN IN YOU
ENTER YOUR CREDENTIALS.
NOW THE STOLEN IT BUT TO THROW
YOU OFF THAT YOU JUST MEN --
HACKED OF THE THROAT THE STOCKY
SIGN WARNING SAYING -- OUR SITE
ARE YOU KNOW WE TRY AGAIN SO
THAT WE THINK -- SOME JUST WRONG
WITH THE SYSTEM AND IF YOU
NOTICE THE OVEN SPELLED WRONG
WRONG THERE -- NOW THE BAG I HAS
YOUR STUFF HE LOGS IN AS YOU HE
READS YOUR INFORMATION AT WORK
FOR MONTHS UNTIL HE KNOWS HOW
YOUR OFFICE RUNS.
AND THEN WHEN THIS NICE FAMILIES
ABOUT TO BUY A HOUSE -- HE
CHANGES THE WIRE INSTRUCTIONS
LIKE WE SPOKE OF EARLIER AND
THEN YOU END UP WANTING IT TO
ONE OF THOSE MONEY MEALS --
HERE'S A REAL ONE FROM SANTA
THERESA I CHANGE THE NAMES AND
SO FORTH BUT I'M I LEFT THAT IN
THERE SO YOU POINT OUT TO THE
AYE.
THE A LOT OF TIMES THE I WILL
NOT BE CAPITALIZE THAT THE DEAD --
DEAD GIVEAWAY ALSO IF YOU SEE
THE WORD KINDLY USED A LOT --
IT'S PROBABLY FRAUDULENT THIS
GUY DIDN'T REALIZE HE'D WIRED
THE MONEY THE WRONG PLACE WE MET
IN PERSON WITH HIS ESCROW
OFFICER AT FOUR FORTY FIVE
INDEED WIRED THE MONEY EARLIER
THAT MORNING.
AND THE ESCROW OFFICER SAID --
WE DON'T USE BE OF A WE USE
WELLS FARGO AND THEN THAT WAS
NOT A GOOD PLACE TO BE.
AND NOW THE BAG I HAS THE MONEY
AND WE HEAR THESE ALL THE TIME
PEOPLE LOSING THEIR LIFE SAVINGS
IT'S VERY SAD [INAUDIBLE]
ONLINE.
ALL THE NEEDS OF THAT.
IS MONEY [INAUDIBLE] EIGHTY SO
THIS IS SO COMMON WE HAVE.
YOU KNOW CARTOONS ABOUT IT BUT
SO WE HAVE TO START TAKING IT
SERIOUSLY AND DOING SOMETHING IS
SOCIETY BECAUSE IT IS GOING TO
BANKRUPT US.
AND THE EASIEST THING FOR ALL
YOU TO TELL YOUR FAMILIES -- IF
YOU'RE DOING A REAL ESTATE THE
BEST WAY TO MITIGATE THIS IS
WHAT WE CALL TWO FACTOR
AUTHENTICATION -- BUT THE THAT
WOULD HAVE TO BE DONE ON THE
ESCROW PERSON SIDE.
BUT WHAT YOUR FAMILY CAN DO IS
WHAT I CALL TWO FACTOR
AUTHENTICATION WHICH IS
BASICALLY MAKE THE PHONE CALL
WHEN YOU GET CHANGED WIRE
INSTRUCTIONS RIGHT BEFORE CLOSE
OF ESCROW CALL AND DON'T CALL
THE PHONE NUMBER IN THE EMAIL.
CALL THE PHONE NUMBER YOU KNEW
FROM THE BEGINNING AND SAY DO
YOU GUYS JUST CHANGE BANKS AFTER
BEING WITH B. OF A FOR TWENTY
FIVE YEARS. FOR MY TRANSACTION
WE'RE GOING TO GO WITH WELLS
FARGO AND THEY'LL SAY NO WE
DIDN'T.
NOW YOU SAVE YOUR LIFE SAVINGS --
THERE IS INSURANCE THAT PROTECTS
AGAINST THIS BUT GENERALLY CYBER
INSURANCE IS EXPENSIVE FOR
BUSINESSES AND IT DOES NOT GUARD
AGAINST THIS KIND OF LOS BECAUSE
THIS IS CONSIDERED SOCIAL
ENGINEERING.
SOCIAL ENGINEERING INSURANCE IS
AVAILABLE IT'S EXTREMELY
EXPENSIVE IT'S LIKE BUYING
EARTHQUAKE INSURANCE SO.
BE CAREFUL LIKE A TONY AND
JACKIE SAID IT'S PREVENTION IS
THE KEY.
AND THAT'S IT THANK YOU
[INAUDIBLE]
ANY GRANDKIDS.
FULL TO QUESTION OKAY AFTER
SINCE WE'RE RUNNING A LITTLE.
BEHIND THANK YOU CAME OUT.
RIGHT FOR ME YES RIGHT. TO THE
SEA.
IT SHOULD BE ON THE DESKTOP.
GOOD MORNING EVERYBODY I MÀ
ROBERT ARTHUR.
I'M A DETECTIVE WITH THE VENTURA
COUNTY SHERIFF'S OFFICE I
CURRENTLY WORK -- IN CYBER CRIME
INVESTIGATIONS WITH CHEMO
[INAUDIBLE]
AND I WAS ASKED TO COME TO TALK
ABOUT -- SOME ADDITIONAL THREATS
RIGHT NOW TO THE COMMUNITY TO
SMALL BUSINESSES SO IT'S GOING.
TO KIND OF PIGGY BACK A LITTLE
BIT ON WHAT TONY TALK ABOUT
CHEMO TALK ABOUT -- WE'RE GONNA
DIVE A LITTLE DEEPER AND A FEW
OTHER -- SCHOOL THREATS.
SO NOW WE'RE TYSON RANSOMWARE --
YOU MAY HAVE HEARD RANSOMWARE
MELBOURNE TASTE MIGHT BE A NEW
TERM FOR YOU WILL TALK ABOUT
WHAT THAT IS AND THE IDEA BEHIND
THESE IS YOUR DATA IS A HOT CAN
BE HOSTAGE IT'S GOING TO BE.
HELD FOR RANSOM -- AND YOU CAN
HAVE TO PAY TO GET THAT BACK OR
HOPEFULLY YOU HAVE OTHER
SECURITY MEASURES IN PLACE AND
WE'RE GOING TO TALK ABOUT SOME
OF THE ISSUES COMING UP WITH
THIS.
SO TEST YOUR STUPIDITY RIGHT THE
PROBLEM IS A LOT OF PEOPLE YOU
TALK TO THEM ABOUT THESE TYPES
OF SCAMS OR YOU KNOW.
A RANSOM WHERE THEY GO I'M NOT
STUPID ENOUGH TO FALL FOR THAT --
BUT AS CHEMO TALK ABOUT IN IN
TWENTY TALK ABOUT WE'RE NOT
DEALING FOR THE MOST PART WHICH
IS SOME LOW LEVEL -- CRIMINALS
RETIREMENT PEOPLE THEY'RE VERY
SOPHISTICATED THEY GO TO THE
LONG -- THEY TAKE STEPS TO MAKE
SURE THAT THESE CRIMES ARE WELL
POLISHED AND IT'S VERY EASY TO
FALL FOR THESE A MINISTRY SOME
EXAMPLES A LITTLE BIT HERE --
AND IT'S VERY EASY FOR JUST
ABOUT ANYONE THE COMMUNITY OR
BUSINESS TO FALL FOR SOME THE
SCAMS IT'S NOT AS SIMPLE AS TO
SPOT SOME OF THESE.
THIS IS A SCREEN RIGHT HERE IN
IF ANYONE SEEN SCRIPT POP UP ON
YOUR COMPUTER ISRAEL BECAUSE IT
POPPED UP ON MY COMPUTER AT WORK.
SO.
WITH LITERALLY ALL FIND I THINK --
WHAT ABOUT COME TO CHECK ON THE
WEATHER IN THIS LAST RAINY
SEASON AND ALSO AND I GET GOOGLE
CHROME CREDIBLE OR THAT?
UP.
THAT'S INTERESTING OUR ESKIMO
TALK ABOUT IT MAY BE A LITTLE
HARD TO READ BUT I'M GONNA READ
A COUPLE THESE LINES THE VERY
FIRST LINE UP THERE.
THERE WAS A DANGER IS TRY TO GET
AN ACCESS TO YOUR PERSONAL LOG
INS -- ANOTHER ONE HERE THERE IS
A GREAT THREAT OF LEAKING OF
YOUR PERSONAL DATA.
I DON'T THE GOOGLE IS GOING TO
PUT OUT A NOTICE LIKE THAT
OBVIOUSLY RIGHT AWAY I RECOGNIZE
THIS IN A LOT OF YOU'LL BE ALL
YEAH THAT'S THAT'S OBVIOUSLY A
SCAM -- THIS IS WHAT WOULD BE
KNOWN AS SCREEN WHERE IT'S A POP
UP THAT COMES UP ON YOUR SCREEN
AND THE IDEA IS TO SCARE PEOPLE
THE IDEA IS TO PUT SOME FEAR.
ON TO SOMEBODY THAT ALL MY GOSH
SOMETHING REALLY IS WRONG WITH
MY COMPUTER -- BUT BEING THAT
THEY GOT A HOLD OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS INVESTIGATE
CYBER CRIME I THOUGHT I'M GONNA
PLAY ALONG SO THERE'S A WHOLE
ONE EIGHT HUNDRED NUMBER.
ONE TOLL FREE NUMBER SO I CALLED --
THESE NEXT FEW SLIDES ARE GONNA
GO IS ACTUALLY CONVERSATION I
HAD WITH THIS PERSON -- IT IS
VERY QUITE SAID RECORDED ON MY
PHONE SO WE'LL SEE HOW THE IDEA
COMES OUT OF IT DOESN'T COME OUT
WELL ALL TO GET THROUGH AND TELL
YOU HOW IT WENT.
I WANT YOU IF YOU CAN HEAR TO
PAY ATTENTION TO MY CONVERSATION
WITH THIS THIS LADY -- SHE HAS A
THICK ACCENT BUT SHE'S.
AGAIN WELL POLISHED SHE'S GOT
ANSWERS SHE KNOWS WHAT SHE'S
TALKING ABOUT SHE'S LEADING ME
THROUGH MY COMPUTER ON WHERE TO
ENTER CERTAIN INFORMATION.
ULTIMATELY SHE'S TRYING TO GET
ME TO LOG INTO A SERVER.
OUT OF THE COUNTRY THAT'S GOING
TO ALLOW REMOTE ACCESS FOR HER
ONCE THEY HAVE REMOTE ACCESS MY
COMPUTER THEY CAN DO WHAT THEY
WANT THEY CAN LOCK DOWN MY FILES
THEY CAN START -- ADDING VIRUSES
MALWARE TO MY SYSTEM I HAVE EVEN
GO THAT FAR WITH IT BUT YOU'LL
SEE I PLEAD STUPID WITH IT WENT
ALONG JUST TO SEE WHAT SHE WOULD
DO SO WE'LL SEE IF THIS PLACE TO
PAY ATTENTION TO HOW -- HOW SHE
IS IN AT THE BEGINNING I'LL TELL
YA I?
IT WAS LONG CONVERSATIONS I JUST
USE CLIPS FROM IT FOR THIS SLIDE
BUT SHE DID TELL ME THE
BEGINNING I KEPT ASKING HOW MUCH
IS GOING TO COST ME AND SHE GETS
THAT ALL IT WITH A HUNDRED
DOLLARS.
SO.
WE'LL SEE IF THIS GOES THROUGH
[INAUDIBLE]
YEAH [INAUDIBLE]
JOHN.
FIRST OF ALL -- WHAT WHAT --
ESTABLISH SUPPORT CONNECTION
[INAUDIBLE]
OKAY.
GOOD FIX MY COMPUTER.
I'M TALKING A MICROSOFT -- COOL.
SHE'S IN FRESNO CALIFORNIA SHE
TELLS ME. FOR A YEAR BOB.
THEY PAY REALLY WELL.
IF YOU'RE VERY SMART -- SEE
SHE'S.
SHE'S OKAY SHE'S NICE AND SMOOTH
POLITE.
THAT ARE JUST ARE NOT TO TRUST
ME [INAUDIBLE]
LATER.
SHE STARTS TO FALTER NOW
[INAUDIBLE]
WHAT WHAT [INAUDIBLE]
SURE.
SO I SEIZE TELL BY THE AND SHE
STARTS TO REALIZE THAT I AM
START TO QUESTION A LITTLE BIT
NOW ALSO IN HER POLISH SCRIPT
ISN'T SELLING SO GOOD YOU NOT
WHAT SURE WHAT TO SAY.
WHEN SHE FIRST TOLD ME OH YEAH
THE SERVERS AND FRESNO
CALIFORNIA KINDA LAUGHED MYSELF
YEAH RIGHT WELL THEN I LOOKED IT
UP?
SURE ENOUGH APPARENTLY THERE IS
A SERVER IN FRESNO CALIFORNIA
FOR MICROSOFT SO THAT JUST GOES
TO SHOW YOU THESE PEOPLE ARE
DOING THE RESEARCH -- SHE THAT'S
PROBABLY A QUESTION SHE GETS
VERY OFTEN I WILL OUT AT ONE
POINT SHE DID ASK ME HOW OLD I
WAS AND I LIGHT A TOURIST FIFTY
YEARS OLD SHOES ALL YOU'RE VERY
YOUNG.
SO FIFTY IS YOUNG FIRST OFF AND
APPARENTLY THE CLIENTELE SHE
USUALLY GETS IS OBVIOUSLY MUCH
OLDER THAN THAT THEY TARGET ON
ELDERLY BECAUSE THEY KNOW.
THAT THEIR THE CHEMO SAID THE
BRAIN NOT GONNA BE AS TECH SAVVY
SO -- THIS WAS A DIFFERENT
SITUATION FOR HER.
SO LET'S TALK ABOUT A COUPLE
THESE ARE NOW OVER TIES INTO
RANSOMWARE VÀ MELTER TIES IS
BASICALLY MALICIOUS ADVERTISING
ONLINE -- HOW MANY GO TO
WEBSITES AND YOU'RE JUST
BOMBARDED WITH BANNERS AND
ADVERTISING WHETHER IT'S YOU
KNOW THINGS YOU LOOKED UP BEFORE
AND THEN IT'S TRACKING -- YOUR
INTERESTS EITHER WAY SO MANY
WEBSITES ARE NOW USING
ADVERTISING FOR INCOME.
BUT A LOT OF BAD GUYS ARE NOW
REALIZING THEY CAN USE THAT
ADVERTISING TO INJECT MALICIOUS --
NOW WHERE IN THERE AND IF YOU
CLICK ON IT YOU'RE GONNA START
THAT.
AS WELL AS SOME OF THESE --
WEBSITES THIS THIS MALWARE CAN
ACTUALLY START TO INFECT YOUR
COMPUTER EVEN WITHOUT BEING
CLICKING ON IT -- THERE'S
DIFFERENT SITUATIONS WHERE
OBVIOUSLY IF YOU HAVE ADDS THAT
MOTION EVERYTHING GOING YOU HAVE
LIKE A DEAL BE FLASH RUNNING
THERE WAS A BIG -- BRIE -- HOLES
IN THE ADOBE FLASH PROGRAM A
COUPLE YEARS AGO THE NEED TO BE
PATCHED.
AS YOU CAN SEE UP THERE THERE'S
A FEW VERY POPULAR WEBSITES NEW
YORK AND THEN B. C. YOUTUBE
SPOTIFY REALTOR DOT COM NOT
SAYING DON'T GO THESE WEBSITES.
BUT THEY WERE KNOWN TO HAVE A
GREAT DEAL OF MALVERN TIES IN.
INSIDE THEIR ADS -- AGAIN I'M
NOT SAYING DON'T GO TO THESE AS
LONG AS YOU HAVE GOOD SECURITY
MEASURES YOU KNOW ANTI VIRUS AND
YOU'RE NOT CLICKING AND YOU HAVE
GOOD ONLINE HYGIENE.
YOU'RE PROBABLY OKAY RANSOMWARE
RANSOMWARE THE MORE COMMON TERMS
AROUND SINCE THE EIGHTIES AND
THAT'S THE IDEA THAT YOUR DATA
THROUGH MALWARE CAN NOW BE
LOCKED DOWN BY THE BAD GUYS IN
THE ONLY WAY YOU'RE GONNA GET
THAT DOWN.
GET THAT BACK.
IS THROUGH.
TRYING TO PAY THEM THEY'RE GOING
TO ASK FOR MONEY AND THERE'S NO
GUARANTEE YOU'RE GETTING THAT --
THAT INFORMATION BACK THESE --
MALWARE CAN BE STARTED THROUGH
PHISHING EMAILS THROUGH THE MAIL
FOR TIGHTENING DOWNLOADS
WEBSITES -- IT IS A STILL A VERY
BIG PROBLEM I KNOW CHEMO SHOWED
HIS STATS I THINK YOU MIGHT ASK
YOU DOES I CAN'T PROVE THAT YET
BUT I'M WORKING ON IT.
SO FOR SOME OF THE POP WE GIVE
TALK ABOUT HOW -- YEAH I'M NOT
STUPID TO FALL FOR THAT KIND OF
STUFF BUT YOU KNOW THEY THEY
THERE MIGHT BE MISS SOME SPELL
WORDS IN HERE BY THE USE A LOT
OF THE BOWLS LÀ THE SEALS ARE
DIFFERENT AGENCY SO YOU'VE GOT
OBVIOUSLY THE FBI SEAL
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
THIS WILL BE ANOTHER -- YOU KNOW
EITHER A SCREEN LOCKER SCREEN
SCREEN WHERE THAT'S BASICALLY
SAYING HEY YOU'VE BEEN LOOKING
AT ILLEGAL STUFF ONLINE YOU'RE
GONNA HAVE TO PAY MONEY IT
USUALLY GIVE YOU INSTRUCTIONS TO
GIVE YOU A TIME LIMIT -- THIS IS
MORE OF A RANSOMWARE SITUATION
WHERE THE COMPUTER HAS BEEN
LOCKED DOWN OR FILES HAVE BEEN
LOCKED DOWN IN THIS WOULD POP UP
ON YOUR COMPUTER AS YOU CAN SEE
IT SAYS IT'S BEEN ENCRYPTED --
IT GIVES A NICE COUNTDOWN FOR
YOU IT'S A YOU COMPLAIN BIT COIN
AND WE'LL TALK ABOUT THAT A
MINUTE HERE -- VERY WELL PUT
TOGETHER AND OBVIOUSLY GONNA
SCARE A LOT OF PEOPLE.
A COMMON BLUESCREEN YOU MIGHT
SEE ON WINDOWS COMPUTERS WILL
THIS ONE WAS CREATED AGAIN BY A
SOME HACKERS THAT BASICALLY
TRYING TO SCARE PEOPLE SAY YOU
GOT A BIG PROBLEM IN YOUR
COMPUTER BUT HEY HERE'S A TOLL
FREE NUMBER WE WOULD LOVE TO
HELP YOU OUT WITH THIS AND IT'S
VERY.
SIMILAR TO THE PERSON I CALLED
ARE GONNA BE THE SAME IDEA --
HERE'S A NICE WELL PUT TOGETHER
YOU'VE GOT THREE DIFFERENT
AGENCIES LOGOS AT THE TOP THERE
TO MAKE IT LOOK VERY OFFICIAL
CONSTRUCTIONS.
EVEN AS A VERY NICE LITTLE TO
TORY ON THE RIGHT SEEN OKAY YOU
HAVE TO PAY AS TO GET YOUR FILES
BACK STEP.
ONE GO TO WALMART OR KMART.
WITH YOUR MONEY STEP TO BUY A
MONEY PACK STEP THREE COME BACK
IN YOU ENTER THE CODE FROM THE
BACK OF THE MONEY PACK RIGHT
HERE IT'S ALL SPELLED OUT NICE.
AND SIMPLE FOR YOU.
NOW THIS ONE SAYS YOU NEED TO
PAY THREE HUNDRED DOLLARS AND
WE'LL TALK ABOUT THIS ONE IS
USING MONEY PACKED THE LAST ONE
WAS USING THAT POINT BUT THE
IDEA IS THE SAME.
THEY'VE LOCKED DOWN YOUR FILES
AND THE ONLY WAY YOU'RE GONNA
GET BACK SOME OF THESE FILES IS
BY PAIN US.
NOW WHEN IT COMES TO SMALL
BUSINESSES WRITTEN LARGE
BUSINESSES YOU KNOW YOUR FILES
MAY BE EVERYTHING TO YOU WHETHER
IT'S INTELLECTUAL PROPERTY OR
WHETHER IT'S YOUR YOU KNOW.
FAMILY PHOTOS AT HOME.
THIS REALLY SCARES A LOT OF
PEOPLE IN IT SHOULD.
OUR THIS IS A VERY CALM ON THE
CAME OUT TO SEE A A SPECIAL
AGENT AGAIN THEY'RE SAYING WE
HAVE -- YOUR COMPUTER'S FILES
ARE LOCKED DOWN THIS ONE IS
FUNNY BECAUSE IN THE MIDDLE IT
BASICALLY SAYS BUT AN EARLY BIRD
SPECIAL ONE HUNDRED DOLLARS IF
YOU PAY NOW BUT IF YOU WAIT.
IT'S GOING TO GO TO TWO FIFTY
AND THEN AFTER THAT IT'S FIVE
HUNDRED DOLLARS SO -- THESE GUYS
ARE ENTREPRENEURS TO WRITE THEY
KNOW.
PEOPLE ARE GONNA JUMP AT THAT
LOWER NUMBER PROBABLY QUICKLY IT
RATHER THAN WAITING.
ANOTHER BIG POINT.
THIS IS AN INTERESTING SLIDE
THIS WAS BASICALLY LIKE A LIVE
MAP THAT WAS CREATED WHEN ONE OF
THOSE -- BAD NOW WHERE RELEASES
WENT THROUGH -- THERE WAS -- I
TALK ABOUT LIKE ADOBE FLASH HAD
A LOT OF HOLES IN THEIR THEIR
SOFTWARE AND THEY WERE NOT PATCH
SO THIS WAS A LIVE MAP THAT WAS
CREATED SHOWING.
THE SPREAD OF MALWARE THROUGH
UNPATCHED SYSTEMS AS YOU LOT --
EASTERN EUROPE -- IN ASIA AREA
JUST AN INTERESTING.
VISUAL HOW FAST THESE CAN SPREAD.
SO WE TALK ABOUT HAVING TO PAY
THESE BAD GUYS -- DO YOU PAY
YOUR DO NOT PAY IT IS OBVIOUSLY
A RECOMMENDATION LÀ FORTY YOU
DO NOT PAY BECAUSE THIS JUST
ENCOURAGES THE BEHAVIOR THIS
ENCOURAGES -- THE FACT THEY
STILL HAVE A MARKET TO DO THAT
BUT A LOT OF PEOPLE DO A LOT OF
BUSINESSES DO -- AND A LOT
DOESN'T GET REPORTED -- CHEMO
SHOULD SOME STATS UP THERE
THAT'S JUST WHAT WAS REPORTED
WHAT WE KNOW OF OBVIOUSLY A LOT
OF THIS IS PR IN SOME COMPANIES
DON'T WANT TO HAVE NEGATIVE
PUBLICITY SO -- WE DON'T EVEN
KNOW OF ALL THE ONES THAT HAVE
HAPPENED.
SO A COUPLE THOSE WAYS TO PAY
THEY SAID HEY GO TO WALMART GET
A MONEY PACK.
THESE ARE ALL KEY WORDS ARE KEY
TERMS THAT SHOULD BE -- KNOWN
ESPECIALLY FOR THE COMMUNITY
VIEW HERE MONEY GRAMM WESTERN
UNION PREPAID MONEY PACK GREEN
DOT EVEN ITUNES WE HAD A CASE
HERE LOCALLY WITH A POOR LADY --
SENIOR CITIZEN OF GOT MOST POP
UPS CALLED HAVE A COMPUTER FIXED
ABOUT THIRTY THOUSAND DOLLARS
LEADER IN ITUNES GIFT CARDS --
WE HAD HER COMPUTER AND WERE.
FINDING ALL THESE ITUNES GIFT
CARDS OR STAND IN AND BASICALLY
THE BAD GUY SO.
YOU TOOK A PROBABLY ABOUT A
HUNDRED OR A FIVE DOLLAR
COMPUTER THE BECAME A THIRTY
THOUSAND DOLLAR COMPUTER BECAUSE
SHE CONSTANTLY WAS PAYING TO
HAVE IT FIXED AGAIN.
JUST FALLING VICTIM NOT
UNDERSTANDING HOW IT WORKS VERY
SAD STORY.
ARE AND WHY THESE HAVE ALWAYS
BEEN COMMON AND THEY WILL
CONTINUE TO BE COMING BECAUSE
HOW SIMPLE AS THIS.
YOU TELL SOMEBODY OKAY GO TO
WALMART BRING YOUR CASH BY THIS.
ARE YOU MAY -- PRE -- LOADED
CARD WITH YOUR MONEY COME BACK
IN ON ALL THE BACK OF THESE ALL
THESE CARDS THERE'S GOING TO BE
A STE A KEY ON THE BACK OR EIGHT
DIGIT -- OF LETTERS AND NUMBERS
AND THAT BASICALLY GRANTS ACCESS
TO THAT CARD SO ONCE YOU GIVE
THAT NUMBER UP THE BAG A THEN
CAN ACCESS ALL THE FUNDS IN
THOSE CARDS.
VERY SIMPLE AS OPPOSED TO
TELLING SOMEONE OKAY GO GET A
CRYPTOCURRENCY WALLET -- THE
LOAD BIG COIN GO THROUGH AN
EXCHANGE.
THAT IS OUT THERE WE'LL TALK
ABOUT THAT THIS IS STILL THE
SIMPLEST FORM THIS WILL CONTINUE
TO BE THE CASE BECAUSE IT IS
EASY.
WHAT ARE WE SEEING MORE AND MORE
THESE DAYS [INAUDIBLE]
CRYPTO CURRENCIES.
THEY'RE ALL AROUND THE WORLD.
THEY'RE USED EVERYWHERE -- BIG
COIN IS ON THERE IS WILD LOT OF
THE OTHER TYPES A BIT -- CRYPTO
CURRENCIES.
THEY'RE POPPING OUT BIG COIN IS
THE BIG ONE STILL EVERYONE'S BY
HEARD A BIT COIN WHAT IS BIG
CUENTA WHAT IS NOT A A TALK
ABOUT WHAT THE QUEEN IS BUT IT'S
BASICALLY [INAUDIBLE]
COMPUTER COAT.
THAT NICE -- BIT COIN RIGHT
THERE THAT IS YOU SOMEONE'S
ARTISTIC RENDITION OF IT.
IF YOU RECEIVE BIG COINS RUSHING
MADE.
HAS NO VALUE BESIDES HOW COOL
YOU THINK MIGHT BE BIG COIN IS
LITERALLY COMPUTER CODE.
AND IT'S GOTTEN NO PHYSICAL
ATTRIBUTES TO IT.
WHY DO A LOT OF THESE HACKERS
LIKE?
CRYPTO CURRENCIES LIKE BIT COIN
BY THE WAY THERE'S THERE'S
HUNDREDS NOT AND THOUSANDS OF
DIFFERENT CRYPTO CURRENCIES
AGAIN BIT COIN IS THE LARGEST IN
THE MOST POPULAR.
BUT THERE ARE MANY OUT THERE.
THE IDEA BEHIND IT IS.
THEIR DECENTRALIZED WHAT IS
DECENTRALIZED MEANING THERE'S NO
BANK THAT.
SEES THESE THERE'S NO GOVERNMENT
THAT OVERSEES THESE YOU CAN
REMAIN ANONYMOUS ON IT THE IDEA
IS IT IS ESTABLISHED ON A
PLATFORM OF COMPUTERS.
KNOWS ON AND ON THE NETWORK.
WE'LL TRACK ALL THE TRANSACTIONS
ALL THE ACTIVITIES AND IMPROVE
THE APPROVED THE DIFFERENT
TRANSACTIONS OF CRYPTO
CURRENCIES IT IS NOT IN ANY
GOVERNMENT IT'S NOT ONE BANK IT
IS SPREAD OUT EVERYWHERE THERE
IS NO ONE EIGHT HUNDRED BIT COIN
THERE IS NO SUPPORT FOR BIT COIN.
IT IS JUST A PROGRAM.
AND THAT'S WHY THESE HACKERS AND
THESE YOU KNOW DARK WHAT PEOPLE
LIKE IT'S BECAUSE THEY CAN
REMAIN ANONYMOUS AND THEY'RE NOT
UNDER THE UMBRELLA OF THE BANK
OR GOVERNMENT.
OUR C. PRICE THINK OKAY YOU KNOW
THIS STUFF HAPPEN I'VE HEARD
ABOUT IT BUT YOU KNOW THIS IS
HOLLYWOOD STUFF WELL IT REALLY
IS HOLLYWOOD STUFF BECAUSE HERE
SOME HEADLINES HOLLYWOOD
HOSPITAL TO PAY SEVENTEEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN BITCOIN. TO
HACKERS.
MANY BIG CITIES AND EVEN SMALL
CITIES HAVE FALLEN VICTIM TO
RANSOMWARE BALTIMORE ATLANTA
TALLAHASSEE JUST A FEW TO NAME
WERE RANSOMWARE HIT THEM THEIR
SERVICES WERE SHUT DOWN.
THERE -- THEIR FILES WERE LOCKED
DOWN A REALLY SLOW -- SHUT DOWN
OPERATIONS FOR THE CITIES.
FED EX WAS A HIT REALLY HARD
WITH ONE THESE BIG -- CYBER
ATTACKS THREE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS LOST.
THIS IS AN ENTRY ARTICLE I JUST
CAME ACROSS ACTUALLY PREPARING
FOR THIS -- THEY PULLED A BUNCH
OF SMALL BEATEN AND MEDIUM
BUSINESS EXECUTIVES AND OWNERS
AND ASK HEY WOULD YOU BE WILLING
TO PAY A RANSOM WHERE IF YOU
WERE.
LOCKED OUT YOUR YOU KNOW DATA
AND THE MAJORITY SAID ABSOLUTE
YES I WOULD AND THAT IS WHY
THESE CRIMINALS STILL HAVE A
MARKET BECAUSE THEY KNOW HOW
VALUABLE DATA IS.
I JUST A FEW STEPS TO GO TO
THESE ARE A LITTLE OLDER BUT IN
THE BEGINNING A TWO THOUSAND
NINE THE FIRST QUARTER ALMOST.
ABOUT TWO AND A NINE MILLION
DOLLARS OR HE PAID. TO RANT
SOMEONE EXPECTED A BILLION
DOLLARS.
BY THE END OF THE YEAR.
OUR 72% OF COMPANIES THAT WERE
AFFECTED BY RANSOMWARE COULD NOT
ACCESS THE DATA FOR A FEW DAYS
AND ABOUT A THIRD COULDN'T EVEN
GET IT FOR ABOUT A WEEK.
A FEW MORE STAFF AS YOU CAN SEE
THESE THINGS ARE NOT SLOWING
DOWN THERE INCREASING -- THE
NUMBER BUSINESSES TACKED.
YOU KNOW IS IT IS GETTING MORE
PREVALENT.
THIS IS AN ISSUES THAT I THINK
IT'S VERY CONSERVATIVE BUT ONE
IN FIVE SMALL AND MEDIUM
BUSINESSES WHO PAID A RANSOM.
NEVER GOT THEIR DATA BACK I
THINK IT'S MORE LIKE 50% --
THAT'S A PRETTY CONSERVATIVE
NUMBERS EVEN IF YOU DO PAY THAT
RANSOM THERE'S NO GUARANTEE
YOU'RE GET YOUR DATA BACK WHY
WOULD THESE CRIMINALS.
CARE THEY'VE GOT WHAT THEY WANT
THEY'RE GONNA MOVE ON MOBILE
RANSOMWARE IS A NEW TREND AS
WELL RIGHT EVERYONE'S GOT PHONES
EVERYONE IS DOING MOST OF THEIR
BUSINESS WHETHER IT'S PERSONAL
OR BUSINESS RELATED FROM THEIR
PHONE SO.
WHAT DO YOU KNOW THE CYBER
CRIMINALS THEY KNOW THAT THEY
KNOW WHERE THAT THE DAD ANY
INFORMATION IS SO THEY ARE
FOCUSING ON PHONES TABLETS
MOBILE DEVICES NOW?
THEY CAN INJECT RANSOMWARE OR
EVEN THOSE SCREEN WHERE SCARE
TACTICS LIKE I TALKED ABOUT
THESE CAN BE SET UP ON PHONES AS
WELL.
NOW WE'VE JUST BEEN TALKING
ABOUT NOW FOR TIES IN.
AND RANSOMWARE I'M NOT EVEN
TALKING ABOUT ALL THESE OTHER
SCHEME TO HEAR ABOUT ALL THE
TIME RIGHT SOCIAL ENGINEERING
WHERE THESE PEOPLE ARE DOING
THEIR BACKGROUND CHECKS THERE
KNOWING WHO THEY'RE TARGETING.
WE TALK ABOUT LIKE THE WINDOWS A
MEDIC YOU KNOW PHONE CALLS YOU
CAN GET I MEAN ABOUT PHONE CALL
SAYING HEY YOUR COMPUTER IS NOT
WORKING.
I HAVE A GOOD FRIEND WHO JUST
TOLD ME RECENTLY I GET PHONE
CALLS ALL THE TIME I TELL PEOPLE
I DON'T EVEN OWN A COMPUTER.
AND THEY JUST MOVE ON TO THE
NEXT PERSON BECAUSE THEY KNOW
PLENTY PEOPLE DO.
ARE YOUR GRANDSON'S BEEN
ARRESTED NEEDS MONEY LOTTERY
SCAMS LIKE JERIAN SCANS OF
ROMANCE CAM SCHEMA TALK ABOUT
IRIS SCANS.
ARE GAS PUMP SKIMMERS KEY
LOGGERS YOU KNOW THESE ARE ALL
STILL THREATS THAT WE ARE SEEN
IN LAW ENFORCEMENT THAT WILL
AFFECT NOT ONLY.
THE COMMUNITY BUT BUSINESSES AS
WELL.
AGAIN I TALK ABOUT BUZZ WORDS TO
KEEP AN EYE OUT FOR WESTERN
UNION MONEY GRAM BIT COIN GREEN
DOT ITUNES.
IF YOU SEE THESE WORDS POP UP NO
LEGITIMATE COMPANY ONE ASKING
AND ASKING FOR MONEY UP FRONT
LET ALONE IN THESE TYPES OF
FORMS.
SO WHERE IS ALL THIS HEADING
THIS IS A CURRENT STAT -- FROM
THE IC THREE THE FBI STAT -- IN --
COMPLAINT CENTER AS YOU CAN SEE
BETWEEN 200-014-2000 EIGHT IN
THE TOTAL LOSS AND FROM CYBER
RELATED CRIMES WHAT FROM ABOUT
EIGHT HUNDRED MILLION. TO TWO
POINT SEVEN MILLION FOUR YEARS.
OBVIOUSLY THE COMPLAINTS HAVE
GONE UP NOT AT THE SAME PACE
WHICH I THOUGHT WAS INTERESTING
SO EITHER THAT MEANS THAT.
EACH CRIME IS SEEN A BETTER
REWARD FOR THESE CRIMINALS OR
THE FACT THAT PEOPLE ARE JUST
BASICALLY NOT REPORTING FOR THE
FACTS WE TALKED ABOUT.
IT'S P. BAD PR FOR THE BUSINESS
IT'S EMBARRASSING ALL KINDS OF
DIFFERENT WAYS -- SO THAT'S A
LOT OF THROUGHOUT YOUR REALLY
QUICK BUT FROM A LAW ENFORCEMENT
PERSPECTIVE.
THESE ARE VERY COMMON ONLY
INCREASING -- AND IT'S PUTTING A
GREAT WORKLOAD ON US.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
HI.
MY NAME IS DEBBIE CHIANG I'M
FROM A COMPANY CALLED HACKER.
ONE WHICH IS IN SAN FRANCISCO AT
THE SUBJECT OF THIS DISCUSSION
AND THE TALK IS GOING TO BE --
SLIGHTLY DIFFERENT FROM THE
OTHER.
THREE HACKER ONE IS FOCUSED ON
DIGITAL VULNERABILITIES -- IT
AND ITS MISSION IS TO PROTECT
THE INTERNET I STILL LIKELY NOT
THINGS THAT YOU WILL SEE AND
FRIEND -- IN FRONT OF YOU EVERY
DAY AS A CONSUMER BUT DEFINITELY
AFFECTS YOU.
AT THE OTHER -- WAY THAT THIS
GUY CONVERSATION IS GOING TO BE
DIFFERENT IS THAT WHEN I SAY
HACKERS I AM TALKING ABOUT THE
GOOD ACTORS -- THE WHITE HAT
HACKERS -- INDEPENDENT SECURITY
RESEARCHERS ETHICAL SECURITY
RESEARCHERS INDEPENDENT THIRD
PARTY RESEARCHERS -- THOSE ARE
ALL NAMES.
THAT ARE USED TO DESCRIBE WHAT
WE CALL AND HACKER WHEN HACKERS
SO AND MAKE THAT IMPORTANT
DIFFERENTIATION FROM -- HACKERS
WHICH I WILL CALL BAD ACTORS IN
THIS CASE [INAUDIBLE] ZERO
HACKER ONE IS THE WORLD'S
LEADING PROVIDER OF HACKER
POWERED SECURITY.
HACKER ONE OPERATES A BUG BOUNTY
PROGRAMS THAT CONNECT COMPANIES
AND GOVERNMENTS WITH THE BEST
WHITE HAT HACKERS IN THE WORLD
TO FIND AND FIX VULNERABILITIES
BEFORE MALICIOUS ACTORS EXPLOIT
THEM.
AS OF MAY TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN
WE HAVE OVER FOUR HUNDRED
THOUSAND WHITE HAT HACKERS WHICH
HAVE REGISTERED WITH HACKER. ONE
TO DEFEND THE CUSTOMERS THAT WE
HAVE AS WELL AS THE PUBLIC AS
WELL AS DIFFERENT BRANCHES OF
GOVERNMENT INCLUDING THE YOU THE
UNITED STATES DEPARTMENT OF
DEFENSE.
REMOVING OVER CLOSE TO ONE
HUNDRED THOUSAND VULNERABILITIES
BEFORE THE BAD GUYS DO AND
PREVENTING AN UNTOLD NUMBER OF
BREACHES IN THE PROCESS.
TODAY CYBERSECURITY PRACTICES
ARE SEVERELY OUTDATED IN
CONTRAST TO THE CYBER THREATS
THAT SOCIETY FACES.
WHEN EXPLOITED FOR CRIMINAL
PURPOSES EVEN JUST ONE SINGLE
AND RELATIVELY AND REMARKABLE
SECURITY VULNERABILITY CAN
CREATE HAVOC AS THE EQUIFAX DATA
BREACH GROSSLY REMINDED US OF IN?
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN MANY OTHER
PREACHERS HAVE MADE THE PRESS
INCLUDING THE WANNA CRY
RANSOMWARE ATTACK.
I'M AND I THINK A PREVIOUS
SPEAKER SAID THAT DID THESE
ATTACKS.
DETRIMENTALLY IMPACT SMALL
MEDIUM BUSINESSES BECAUSE 60% OF
THE SMALL MEDIUM BUSINESSES GO
OUT OF BUSINESS SIX MONTHS.
AFTER A DATA BREACH OR SPUR
SECURITY INCIDENT SO WE'RE PROUD
TO HAVE -- AT MANY SMALL AND
MEDIUM BUSINESSES AS PART OF OUR
PORTFOLIO OF CUSTOMERS.
SO NOW ONTO HACKER POWERED
SECURITY AND WHAT EXACTLY IT IS
IT IS WHAT WE THINK IS A
SCALABLE MODEL THAT CAN BE USED
TO PREVENT CYBER ATTACKS IN
SOCIETY AS A WHOLE.
ESPECIALLY FOR ESPECIALLY FOR
SMALL AND MEDIUM BUSINESSES WHO
MIGHT NOT BE ABLE TO AFFORD THE
EXPENSIVE CONSULTANTS AND
PENETRATION TAX.
AKA POWERED SECURITY COVERS ANY
CYBERSECURITY ENHANCING SERVICES
AND AUTOMATION'S THAT ARE
PARTIALLY OR WHOLLY PRODUCED BY
INDEPENDENTLY OPERATING SECURITY
EXPERTS OUTSIDE THE COMPANY OR
ORGANIZATION IN QUESTION.
IT IS A MODEL THAT INVITES
EXTERNAL AND INDEPENDENT
SECURITY RESEARCHERS AND ETHICAL
HACKERS TO HUNT FOR
VULNERABILITIES AND COMPUTERIZED
SYSTEMS.
THESE ARE INDIVIDUAL EXPERTS WHO
HAVE SIGNED UP TO HELP
CORPORATIONS AND ORGANIZATIONS
TO DETECT AND FIX THEIR SECURITY
THE MOST FUNDAMENTAL FUNCTION OF
HACKER POWERED SECURITY IS A
VULNERABILITY DISCLOSURE PROGRAM
ALSO CALLED RESPONSIBLE
DISCLOSURE COORDINATED PHONE
ABILITY DISCLOSURE.
OF HONOR ABILITY TO SOCIAL
PROGRAM IS ESSENTIALLY A
NEIGHBORHOOD WATCH FOR SOFTWARE.
THE MOTTO IS IF YOU SEE
SOMETHING SAY SOMETHING.
CONCRETELY IF AND WHEN AN
ETHICAL HACKER FINDS A SECURITY
VULNERABILITY AND A COMPANY OR
GOVERNMENT ORGANIZATIONS WEBSITE
OR MOBILE APP.
OR OTHER COMPUTER SYSTEM -- THIS
PERCENT WILL BE INVITED TO
DISCLOSE THE VULNERABILITY FOUND
TO THE SYSTEMS OWNER.
YOU CAN BE SURE THAT THE BAD
ACTORS ARE CONSTANTLY HACKING
ANYTHING AND EVERYTHING SO WHY
NOT LEVERAGE THE POWER OF THE
NEIGHBORHOOD WATCH TO GET THOSE.
VULNERABILITIES BEFORE THE BAD
GUYS.
TO MOST HUMAN BEINGS ARE READY
TO HELP THEIR NEIGHBORS OF THE
IMPETUS FOR VULNERABILITY
DISCLOSURE IS ENORMOUS.
SO I ENCOURAGE YOU ALL HERE IF
YOU SEE A BUG.
IN A OUT WEBSITE OR IN IT HE
COMMERCE WEBSITE THAT YOU USE.
I HAD TO REPORT IT TO THE
COMPANY THAT YOU SEE IT.
AS THAT YOU FOUND IT BECAUSE
THAT IS LIKELY A BUG THAT A BAD
ACTOR WILL TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
ISSUES OF LEGALITY AND TRUST
HOWEVER MAKE PHONE ABILITY
DISCLOSURE MORE COMPLICATED THAN
A REGULAR NEIGHBORHOOD WATCH TO
SOLVE THIS ISSUE LEADING
COMPANIES.
HAVE CREATED THEIR OWN POLICY
FRAMEWORKS FOR THE DISCLOSURE OF
VULNERABILITIES TO THEM AND
OTHERS TURN TO COMPANIES SUCH AS
HACKER ONE TO ORGANIZE AND
COORDINATE SUCH PROGRAMS.
WHEN ANTI DID IT ENTITY DECIDES
TO OFFER FINANCIAL REWARDS TO
FINDERS OF VULNERABILITIES THE
VULNERABILITY DISCLOSURE PROGRAM
IT'S CALLED A BUG BOUNTY PROGRAM?
YOU MAY HAVE SEEN THESE IN THE
PRESS -- BUG BOUNTY PROGRAMS
HAVE EXISTED AT LEAST SINCE.
NINETEEN EIGHTY THREE THE
PRACTICE WAS PERFECTED BY GOOGLE
FACEBOOK AND MICROSOFT OVER THE
PAST HALF DOZEN YEARS.
HACKER POWERED SECURITY PROGRAMS
HAVE DEBT DEMONSTRATED THEIR
EFFECTIVENESS COMPARED TO OTHER
METHODS OF ON ABILITY TO
DETECTION.
HAVE HIRING FULL TIME EMPLOYEES
OR EXTERNAL SERVICE OUR PRODUCT
VENDORS TO TEST FOR
VULNERABILITIES IS MORE
EXPENSIVE EXPENSIVE ESPECIALLY
FOR SMALL AND MEDIUM BUSINESSES.
NO OTHER METHOD FOR VALIDATING
SOFTWARE OR MANUFACTURED
PRODUCTS THERE THAT ARE IN USE
BY CONSUMERS HAS BEEN SHOWN TO
PRODUCE SIMILAR RESULTS.
AT SUCH A FAVORABLE ECONOMIC
UNIT PRICE.
THE QUESTION I GET A LOT IS WHO
ARE THESE HACKERS.
SECURITY EXPERTS MAY BE
DESCRIBED USING A VARIETY OF
TITLES INCLUDING ETHICAL HACKER
WHITE HAD SECURITY RESEARCHER
BOB HUNTER AND FINDER. ONE TITLE
IS CONSPICUOUSLY ABSENT CRIMINAL.
HACKERS ARE NOT CRIMINALS
SPECIFICALLY BY BODY PLATFORMS
OFFER NO BENEFIT TO SOMEONE WITH
CRIMINAL INTENT.
ON THE CONTRARY HACKER ONE WILL
BE CAUGHT WE WILL RECORD DATA.
ABOUT EVERY HACKER ON THE
PLATFORM AND ONLY REWARD ACTIONS
THAT FOLLOW THE RULES. FOR THESE
REASONS CRIMINALS GO ELSEWHERE.
HACKERS ARE DRIVEN A VARIETY OF
MOTIVATIONS MANY OF WHICH ARE
ALTRUISTIC.
THE SECURITY ADVOCATES ADVOCACY
ORGANIZATION I AM THE CALVARY
SUMMARIZES THESE MOTIVE IS THE
MOTIVATIONS AS PROTECT.
MAKE THE WORLD A SAFER PLACE
PUZZLE TINKER OUT OF CURIOSITY
PRESTIGE SEEK PRIDE AND
NOTABILITY.
PROFIT TO EARN MONEY.
AND AND PATRIOTISM IDEOLOGICAL
AND PRINCIPLED.
A TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN STUDY BY
THE UNITED STATES NATIONAL
TELECOMMUNICATIONS AND
INFORMATION ADMINISTRATION
WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT OF
COMMERCE.
FOUND THAT ONLY 15% OF SECURITY
RESEARCHERS EXPECT FINANCIAL
COMPENSATION IN RESPONSE TO
AVAILABILITY DISCLOSURE.
AND NOW I WANT TO THE TYPES OF
BUGS THAT OUR GUYS FIND.
SO THESE ARE THE TYPES OF
VULNERABILITIES -- THAT OUR MOST
POPULAR -- POPULARLY FOUND ON
OUR A BUYER HACKERS.
XSS WHICH IS CROSS SITE
SCRIPTING THAT'S THE ABILITY TO
RUN CHAVIS JAVA SCRIPT CODE IN A
VICTIMS WEB BROWSER -- SO IF YOU
HAVE AN EXERCISE BIKE AND G.
EMAIL -- THE HAT.
A BAD ACTOR OR CRIMINAL CAN DO
WHAT YOU WOULD AT WHAT YOU
ORDINARILY WOULD DO WHICH IS
SENDING READ EMAILS.
OF FROM YOUR ACCOUNT. 38% OF OUR
HACKERS LIKE SEARCHING FOR THIS
ONE SO THIS IS THE MOST COMMON
BUT THAT WE FIND FOR CUSTOMERS.
SIEGEL INJECTION THE ABILITY TO
CONTROL DATABASE QUERIES
PASSWORDS ENCRYPTED PASSWORDS
AND FINANCIAL DATA.
THIS IS SECOND PLACE THIRTEEN
POINT 5% OF OUR HACKERS FIND
THESE KINDS OF BUGS BEFORE THE
BAD GUYS DO.
ARE THE MOST COMMON TYPE IN ONE
PARTICULAR SEGMENT WHICH IS A
FINANCIAL SERVICES AND FAN TACK --
WHICH MADE A COVER SOME OF THE
REAL STATES AT BROKERAGE FORM AT
FIRMS.
IS THAT IS THAT IMPROPER
AUTHENTICATION I'M SO AN EXAMPLE
OF IMPROPER AUTHENTICATION ISN'T
I DOOR ATTACK IT ALLOWS YOU TO
SEE ANOTHER PERSON'S RECEIPT --
AND SEE OTHER PEOPLE'S DATA --
BY ACCIDENT BECAUSE THE CODE
WASN'T DIDN'T ACCOMMODATE FOR
THIS PARTICULAR SITUATION.
ANOTHER COMMON BUG IS S. S. R.
F. ACCESS TO INTERNAL NETWORK.
IF SOMETHING IS HOSTED ON A
CLOUD HACKERS COULDN'T ACT COULD
GET AN ACCESS KEY TO
AUTHENTICATION FOR THOSE
INSTANCES.
ACCESS INTERNAL TOOLS OF
EMPLOYEES AND NOT INSIDERS
ACCESS CLOUD INSTANCES AND
BASICALLY STEAL DATA.
WHY DO THESE BIKES HAPPEN?
WE BELIEVE THAT BIKES HAPPEN
BECAUSE ENGINEERS -- AREN'T
REALLY THINKING OF USER INPUT --
AT THE TIME THAT THEY'RE WRITING
THE CODE -- THEIR STRESS FOR
RELEASES AND PRESSURE FOR GROWTH
SECURITY TENDS TO BE A DEFAULT --
IF THERE'S NO Q. AND A TEAM OR
SECURITY TEAM THE RELEASE APPS
OR TOOLS BUGS WITH THEM.
I AM HOWEVER YOU GUYS COMPANIES
CAN LEVERAGE THE POWER OF THE
ETHICAL HACKING COMMUNITY TO
FIND THESE BIKES BEFORE BAD
ACTORS DO.
ARE HACKERS ALSO FIND ABOUT HALF
OF THE BIKE THAT WE FIND OUR
MEDIUM SEVERITY AND 15% ARE
CONSIDERED CRITICAL -- SO AGAIN
AS PART OF A SMALL MEDIUM
BUSINESSES STRATEGY WHO CAN'T
NECESSARILY AFFORD TO SECURITY
ENGINEERS -- CONSULTANTS -- I'D
SUGGEST TURNING TO AT THE
HACKING COMMUNITY BY FIRST
HAVING OF VULNERABILITY
DISCLOSURE POLICY.
JUST AT A MINIMUM MINIMUM
SECURITY AT ADDRESS SO IF YOUR
FELLOW NEIGHBOR FINDS A BUG OR
YOUR CUSTOMER FINDS A BUG THEY
HAVE A WAY TO TELL YOU BEFORE A
BAD ACTOR EXPLOITS IT.
AND THEN MOVE ON TO HAVING
AVAILABILITY DISCLOSURE POLICY.
WHICH HAS A COUPLE OF KEY
COMPONENTS AND IT'S SPELLED OUT
THE RULES OF WHAT IS ALLOWED AND
WHAT ISN'T ALLOWED.
AND MOST IMPORTANTLY A SAFE
HARBOR FOR A COMMUNICATOR OF A
BUG.
THAT WAY YOU CAN LEVERAGE THE
FREE HELP THAT THE SECURITY
RESEARCHER COMMUNITY WILL GIVE
YOU.
I'M AND THEN MOST IMPORTANTLY BE
SURE THAT YOU CAN IN TAKE THE
BUGS AND FIX THEM.
I'M A LOT OF THESE BUGS --
PARTICULARLY IN RANSOMWARE
THEY'RE TAKING ADVANTAGE OF
BECAUSE PATCHES WERE NEVER
INSTALLED.
SO IF YOU HAVE TO HAVE THE
ABILITY TO INTAKE THE BUG AND A
PLAN TO REMEDIATE THEM.
THAT'S WHAT ENCOURAGES AND IS
THE MOTIVATION FOR A LOT OF
THESE HACKERS TO DO WHAT THEY DO.
SO INCLUDE TO CLOSE I REPEAT THE
WORD OF NUMEROUS EXPERTS THAT A
UBIQUITOUS SEE SOMETHING SAY
SOMETHING PRACTICE FOR
VULNERABILITIES IS A VITAL AND
CRITICAL STEP TOWARDS IMPROVING
CYBERSECURITY.
FOR CONSUMERS.
HACKER POWERED SECURITY HAS
MATURED AS A MODEL TO BE READY
TO HELP SOCIETY SOLVE ONE OF ITS
MOST PRESSING PROBLEMS SABBATH
[INAUDIBLE]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND AND REALLY AND
EXCELLENCE -- PANEL OF
APPRECIATE YOU ALL JOINING US
HERE AND WHAT I THINK WE'RE
GONNA DO IS BECAUSE WE ARE.
SEEM TO BE RUNNING A LITTLE
SHORT ON TIME -- WE'RE GOING TO
DO QUESTIONS AFTER OR MAYBE IN
THE BACK OF THE ROOM IF YOU HAVE
SOME QUESTIONS BUT THANK YOU AND
CAN WE GIVE A BIG ROUND OF
APPLAUSE TO THIS.
A AND THEN I WOULD LIKE TO BRING
UP OUR SECOND PANEL WE WE DO
HAVE THREE PANELS TOTAL AND I'M
ENCOURAGING ALL PANELISTS.
TO OF BE A LITTLE WARY OF THE
TIME -- SO WE CAN MAKE SURE THAT
WE HEAR EVERYBODY AND SO THE
QUESTION IS WHAT MORE CAN BE
DONE TO EDUCATE AND ENCOURAGE
ADOPTIONS OF CYBER SECURITY BEST
PRACTICES IN CALIFORNIA.
AND OUR SECOND PANEL THIS
MORNING SEEKS TO GATHER
INFORMATION ON THE CURRENT WAYS
IN WHICH WE COMMUNICATE ABOUT
CYBERSECURITY.
AND MORE GENERALLY ABOUT BEST
BUSINESS PRACTICES TO HELP
LEVERAGE EXISTING LINES OF
COMMUNICATION TO EXPAND --
KNOWLEDGE WITH US HERE TODAY --
WE HAVE A KNOWLEDGEABLE PANEL
FROM REAL ESTATE SECTOR SMALL
BUSINESSES AND THE CYBERSECURITY
COMMUNITY.
OF I WOULD LIKE -- TO WELCOME
JIM KEITH WHO WILL BE SPEAKING
FIRST HIS WITH THE BOARD OF
DIRECTORS OF THE VENTURA COUNTY --
COASTAL ASSOCIATION ASSOCIATION
OF REALTORS WE ALSO HAVE CHECK
LACK FROM DILBERT REAL ESTATE.
NANCY HOLE THE PRESIDENT AND CEO
OF THE OXNARD CHAMBER AND THEN
FINALLY WE WILL HAVE THIS ACTUAL
OR WHO IS THE FOUNDER AND CEO OF
AN NGO -- THAT WAS THE VIDEO
THAT WE SOFT -- EARLIER ON THE
VERY COOL VIDEO SO WHAT WE START
WITH GEN.
I BELIEVE JOKES CYNICAL FIRST OF
TRUCK.
WELL IF YOU'D LIKE.
OKAY RIGHT WELCOME AND THANK YOU
FOR ALL OF US PLANNING.
HI I'M CHUCK BLACK ON THE BROKER
FOR DEAL BUT REALTORS WE HAVE
ABOUT SIX HUNDRED AGENTS --
ACROSS NORTHERN LOS ANGELES TWO
OFFICES AND HER ACCOUNT -- WE
HAVE HAD PROBLEMS WITH WIRE TO
PROBLEMS THAT WERE MAJOR THAT I
THEY RESULTED IN SOME
SIGNIFICANT SIX FIGURE LOSSES
FOR SOME CLIENTS.
AND IN TALKING TO OTHER BROKERS
FOR THEIR THEIR COMPANIES THIS
IS OBVIOUSLY NOT SOMETHING THAT
EVERYBODY WANTS.
TO TALK ABOUT AND SAY OKAY WE
HAD THESE HUGE PROBLEM.
OF MOST EVERYBODY HAS HAD THESE
KINDS OF PROBLEMS.
THIS PART -- ONE NOT HAPPEN TO
BE WERE -- THE GENTLEMAN WAS IN
ESCROW FOR A PROPERTY THAT WAS A
LITTLE OVER A MILLION DOLLARS.
HE WAS ASKED -- TO BEND IN HIS
MONEY HE HAD A YUP -- ABOUT A
HUNDRED SEVENTY FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS OF CASH THAT HE HAD TO
SEND TO ESCROW.
SO HE SAID THAT -- JUST PRIOR TO
ESCROW CLOSING THE ESCROW
OFFICER CALLED HIM ON THE PHONE
SAID OKAY WE'RE ABOUT TO CLOSE
IN A COUPLE OF DAYS WE NEED TO
SEND YOUR MONEY.
AND HE SAID WELL I ALREADY DID.
AND SHE WAS THIS.
PERSON STRUCK FOR A SECOND SHIFT
AS WELL.
WHAT I THINK WE GOT A PROBLEM
AND I'VE NEVER CONTACT YOU TO
SEND YOUR MONEY?
SO SHE SENT THE THE THE F. B. I.
A QUICK CALL THE FBI -- CALLED
US TO TALK TO US ABOUT IT THIS
WAS A LITTLE WHILE AGO SO.
THEY DON'T ONE OF THE FIRST
QUESTIONS THEY ASKED US WAS DO
YOU HAVE TWO FACTOR
AUTHENTICATION -- FIRST THING WE
DID WAS GOOGLE IT TO FIND OUT
WHAT IT WAS AT THAT TIME.
OF THE IT'S IT'S GOTTEN A LOT
MORE POPULAR NOW BUT IT WAS
DESCRIBED ALREADY THAT THIS IS
WE HAVE SIX HUNDRED AGENTS AND
THEY ARE ALL INDEPENDENT
CONTRACTORS.
THEY HAVE EMAILS FROM ALL OVER
THE PLACE.
BY THE WAY WE ALSO HAD TO HAVE
AN ESCROW COMPANY AND THAT
ESCROW BENICIA ENDED UP -- ABOUT
A YEAR AND A HALF AGO OF BEING
SHOT DOWN AS FAR AS OUR
COMPUTERS WERE CONCERNED WILL
PLANTS MORE.
THEY HAD A BACKUP.
THEY WENT TO THAT BACK UP AND
THEN THEY HAD TO WORK THROUGH
THE PERIOD OF TIME FROM THAT
BACK UP TO CURRENT.
IT TOOK THEM TWO WEEKS TO GET
THAT DONE.
EVERYBODY WORKING OFF A LOT OF
OVERTIME AND WE BUT THEY HAVE
HIT US A COUPLE OF TIMES.
TO THERE'S JUST THE STABBER
TORSION THAT WE'VE END UP HAVING --
HOW DO THEY GET IN -- I HAPPEN
TO BE LUCKY TO HAVE A BREAKFAST
YESTERDAY WITH TO MY
GRANDCHILDREN OR JUST CAME BACK
FROM COLLEGE. FOR SUMMER
VACATION ONCE FROM PURDUE THE
OTHERS FROM GEORGIA TECH -- BOTH
REALLY GOOD SCHOOLS AT HOME I
WAS GOING TO BE SPEAKING THIS
MORNING ABOUT THIS AND I ASKED
HIM DID DO YOU HAVE THIS.
MAYES ARE ALL YEAH YOU KNOW WE
HAVE TO DO THAT.
WHEN WE SIGN IN AND MY GRANDSON
SO WHEN I. SIGN IN TO GET A
HOMEWORK ASSIGNMENT IN A CLASS?
I PLAN IN OF THE COMPUTER BUT
THEN I HAVE TO GO TO MY PHONE
AND YOU KNOW TYPING YES THIS WAS
ME.
AND ANY KIND OF THOUGHT FOR A
SECOND USES WHY WOULD ANYBODY
REALLY CARE ABOUT WHAT MY
HOMEWORK ASSIGNMENT WAS.
AND IS THE PHONE YOU KNOW MAYBE
IT'S JUST BECAUSE THAT'S JUST A
WAY TO GET IN A BACK DOOR WAY TO
KIND OF LOOK AROUND AND SEE WHAT
THEY HAVE -- WE STRIVE TO LOCK
UP ARE IN INFORMATION BUT OTHERS
SCRIBE REALLY TO TO TRY TO STEAL
IT -- THERE ARE TWO SAFEGUARDS
ONE IS ELECTRONIC THE OTHER ONE
IS HUMAN IT'S US.
WE OFTEN TRY TO PROTECT THIS
INFORMATION USING PROGRAMS BUT
FRANKLY ANY PROGRAM LIKE ANY
LOCK CAN ALWAYS BE BEATEN -- I
HAPPEN TO HAVE A PROFESSIONAL IT
CONSULTANT THAT ALSO WORKS AS AN
AGENT IN MY OFFICE.
HER HUSBAND IS ALSO AN IT
PROFESSIONAL SO I THOUGHT WELL
LET ME LET ME CHECK WITH HER TO
SEE WHAT THEY DO.
USE IT TO PEOPLE WHAT DO YOU DO
AT HOME.
SO I ASKED WHAT PROGRAM THEY USE
THAT SHE'S MY KIND OF SHEEPISHLY
AND THEN SHE SAID WE DON'T USE A
PROGRAM.
AND I SIMPLE.
MET DANGEROUS AND THIS IS WHERE
TO SAFE GOING ON PROGRAM.
THE OTHER ONE IS.
ALWAYS HAVE TO CHANGE
[INAUDIBLE]
HE'S.
PROGRAM LIKE IT BLOCKS NO SENATE
BILL.
AND WHAT THE WAS IT KIND OF
SERVER CAME FROM AND THAT
USUALLY KEEPS US OUT OF TROUBLE.
DIFFERENT WAYS DIFFERENT PEOPLE
ARE DOING THIS THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT -- WE FOUND ONLINE AT AND
IT IT EXPLAINS WHY EIGHTIES
SOMETIMES PEOPLE DON'T NOTICE
THESE THINGS -- SOMETIMES OUR
MINDS CAN MAKE A SEE WHAT WE
EXPECT TO SEE.
MOST OF YOU CAN GO UP THERE AND
START READING THROUGH THAT AND
EVEN THOUGH IT'S TERRIBLY
TERRIBLY MISSPELLED.
IS ALREADY POINTED OUT JUST WITH
SPELLINGS AND EVERYTHING ELSE
YOU CAN READ RIGHT THROUGH THAT --
YOUR YOUR YOUR MIND PUTS THE
FIGURES TOGETHER.
AND THAT'S WHAT THE TOWN ON WILL
SEND SOME OF THESE THINGS THIS
IS SIMILAR TO AN EMAIL THEY SENT
OUT WAS.
AND THE EMAIL THAT THEY HAD WAS
WAS PERFECTLY BE.
LOCATED EXCEPT.
MANY OF THE EMAIL NAMES WERE
CHANGED THE ADDRESSES WHAT THEY
HAD DONE WAS IS THEY THEY PUT
LIKE.
YOU KNOW WELL AND RESPECT BY
TRUCK LIKE A G. MAIL DOT COM
BECAME CHUCK THAT LET THAT G.
MAIL AT MSN DOT COM IS A QUICK
LOOK NOBODY NOTICED ANYTHING
WRONG BECAUSE THAT'S NOT
SOMETHING YOU USUALLY DO.
IS LOOK AT THOSE -- CHUCK THAT
LET IT GO BACK COM BETWEEN TRUCK
THAT LACK THAT BILL BACK AT CS
DOT COM.
THOSE WOULD NOT GO ANYWHERE
BECAUSE THOSE AREN'T REAL EMAIL.
THE ONLY PERSON THAT GAP THAT
EMAIL EVEN THOUGH IT LOOKED LIKE
EVERYBODY ELSE WAS COPIED.
WAS THE UNFORTUNATE PERSON THAT
WAS GOING TO THIS AND OUT MONEY.
WE HAVE WE TALKED ABOUT REALTORS
AND NOT UNDERSTANDING.
AS IT PROFESSIONALS AND
SOMETIMES BEING A AND I THINK
OUR AVERAGE AGE FOR REALTORS
ABOUT FIFTY FOUR YEARS OLD IN
CALIFORNIA.
WE HAVE CLIENTS THAT THIS IS THE
FIRST TIME EVER IN THE HISTORY
OF LIFE THAT THEY HAVE SPENT OUT
A WIRE TRANSFER AND GO UP TO THE
BANK SAID I NEED YOUR HELP TO DO
THIS AND THIS IS WHAT I'VE GOT
TO DO.
AND TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THAT.
SO WE'RE NOT A WE'RE ACTUALLY
WHEN PEOPLE ARE WATCHING US AND
THAT'S WHAT HAPPENED.
OF PEOPLE DO WATCHES THESE TV
EMAIL.
THEY THEY WILL FOR WRITING AN
ENTIRE.
THEY HAVE THIS ALL PREPARED THEY
ENDED UP THEIR TIMING IS PERFECT
AND THEY END UP GETTING THEM UP
INSTEAD OF THE THE RIGHTFUL
PEOPLE.
THIS IS A GREAT MAGAZINE ARTICLE
IT WAS MARCH ELEVENTH TWENTY
EIGHTEEN WHAT I TRY TO DO.
IS WE WE INSTRUCT OUR RATE AND
SO ON AND THIS TWO FACTOR
AUTHENTICATION.
BUT OF COURSE.
THEY'RE USING A LOT OF ELSE.
SO EACH ONE IS DONE DIFFERENTLY.
WE HAVE A TECH PERSON THAT WE
HAVE IN EACH OF OUR OFFICES THAT.
ASSIST THEM WE'RE TRYING TO GET
THAT DONE ENOUGH HOME WE'VE HAD
PROBLEMS THIS IS A BIG PROBLEM
IN THE HISTORY MAKE SURE YOU DO
THIS TWO FACTOR AUTHENTICATION.
ON YOUR MAILS SO WE LOOK FOR A
PROGRAM RIBBON IT'S GOT YOU TWO
VIDEOS AND TELL YOU HOW TO DO IT.
BUT SMALL IS INTERESTING BECAUSE
IT COVERED AN AWFUL LOT OF THE
DETAILS SO I DECIDED TO TAKE A
LOOK AT IT.
IN.
IT COOPER G. EMAIL COPY COVERED
YABU MAIL COVERED AT AM TEN MALE
THEY HAVE TWO FACTOR
AUTHENTICATION.
THE CALL GOT VERY LONG BECAUSE
AT THAT NECK AS IT KEPT GOING ON
THERE'S FACTOR AUTHENTICATION
TOOL AND NOT BASED.
AND ON INSTAGRAM AT SAP AND
TWITTER.
FACEBOOK A LOT OF PEOPLE THAT
ARE IN REAL ESTATE USE THAT A
GREAT DEAL BECAUSE THE HAVING AN
OPEN HOUSE IT'S GOING TO BE HERE
I HOPE YOU COME TO THAT.
AND THAT GUYS TAKE A LOOK AT
THAT AND THEN START LOOKING FOR
THAT ADDRESS IN THEIR EMAILS AS
SOON AS IT GOES INTO ASTRO THEY
START FOLLOWING THAT AS PRO.
AND THEY'RE ABLE TO GET IT AT
THE RIGHT TIME BUT THAT'S NOT
ALL OF THEM.
THEY GO THROUGH APPLE AND
MICROSOFT AMAZON WE BUY A LOT OF
MATERIAL SEE A YAHOO LINKED IN.
A LOT OF PERSONAL INFORMATION.
SNAPCHAT REDDIT.
PINTEREST SLAP DROPBOX ALL OF
THESE WERE IN THEIR ARTICLE ALL
OF THEM HAVE. TWO FACTOR
AUTHENTICATION DROP BOXES WERE
UP BY SHOULDN'T SAY THAT.
THIS IS WHERE I KEEP ALL MY
EMAILS BUT OF COURSE I'VE GOT
THAT CORRECTED.
BUT YOU'VE GOT TO HAVE THOSE
SOMEPLACE BECAUSE EACH ONE OF
THESE TAKE DIFFERENT EMAILS AND
JUST KEEP GOING AND GO.
BY THE WAY EVERNOTE VAN -- WHICH
IS WHAT YOU DO TO A BY UP A PAL
WHICH IS HOW YOU SEND MONEY OUT
TUMBLR.
AND THERE'S TO SPECIFIC PROGRAM.
THAT ARE IN THIS ARTICLE THAT
WERE RECOMMENDED BY P. C.
MAGAZINE KEEP ALL YOUR EMAIL
PASS OFF THEIR PASSWORDS IN AND
THEY HAVE TO FACTOR UP AND THE
QUE.
BY THE WAY THERE'S OTHERS YOU
DON'T THINK OF MASKED.
OF BRINGING A TEAMVIEWER
WORDPRESS GO DADDY.
MAILCHIMP WHERE WE HAVE ALL
THESE THINGS YOU KNOW ALLOWS
PEOPLE TO HEAR WHAT'S GOING ON
IN YOUR HOUSE OR PERHAPS TO SEE
WHAT'S GOING ON IN YOUR HOUSE.
THEY HAVE. TO FACTOR
AUTHENTICATION TO MAKE BETTER
SERVICES MORE SECURE.
OF AND FINALLY SQUARE IN
KICKSTARTER KICKSTARTER IS A
PROGRAM THAT THEY USE.
THE SOMEBODY'S GOT A PROBLEM
THEY WANT TO SET UP A FUND LIKE
GO FOR ME.
AND YOU CAN IMAGINE PEOPLE WILL
END UP WITH DOING A GREAT JOB
RAISING MONEY FOR SOMEBODY AND
THEN THE NEXT THING YOU FIND OUT
AT ALL IT'S ALL GONE.
TURBOTAX THEY'LL LEARN
EVERYTHING ABOUT YOU AND SEE A
BIG IS SHOPPING.
SO CYBER SECURITY IS NOT JUST
ABOUT EMAIL SAID ABOUT
EVERYTHING WE DEAL WITH.
AND WAS CONNECTED TO THE
INTERNET POSSIBLY RESPOND
REFERRED REFRIGERATOR AND THEN
BECOME A DOORWAY TO CYBER CRIMES.
IN CLOSING I'D LIKE TO TELL YOU
A SHORT STORY ABOUT ONE OF MY
AGENTS TRUE STORY.
BUT IN THREE YEARS HE'S HAD
THREE PROBLEMS.
OF WHICH IS MID SIXTIES.
YOUR ONE HE CAME HOME TO FIND
BOXES OF COMPUTERS ON HIS PORCH
SOMEONE HACKED INTO IS CREDIT
CARD AND ORDERED A LOT OF
EXPENSIVE COMPUTERS.
THEY WERE NOTIFIED WHEN THEY
WOULD BE DELIVERED AND PLACED ON
HIS PORCH -- THEY WOULD HAVE
BEEN THERE TO PICK THEM UP BUT
GOOD NEWS FOR BUSH HE LIVES IN A
GATED COMMUNITY AND THEY
COULDN'T GET THROUGH THE GATE.
SO HE WAS ABLE TO RETURN ALL THE
THINGS AND THEN HE SIGNED UP.
WITH -- IN IDENTITY PROTECTION
COMPANY AND TRYING TO PROTECT
THAT BUT THAT DIDN'T SOLVE ALL
THE PROBLEMS BECAUSE NEXT YEAR.
HE SUBMITTED HIS TAX RETURN AND
HE GOT A NOTE BACK FROM THE IRS
SAYING THAT WELL.
YOU KNOW YOU'VE SUBMITTED THE
WRONG FORM YOU'VE ALREADY
SUBMITTED YOUR YOUR TAX RETURN
WE'VE ALREADY SENT YOU THE
RETURN AND AND THE AMOUNT OF
MONEY THAT WE REFUNDED YOU.
AND YOU HAVE TO HAVE A DIFFERENT
FORM IF YOU'RE GOING.
TO MAKE A CORRECTION HE SAYS I
NEVER FILED ANY TAXES AND WHEN
THEY CHECKED ON IT IT WENT TO
SOME PLACE IN KANSAS.
NOT TO HIS HOME ADDRESS
[INAUDIBLE]
YEAR.
THREE AND BY THE WAY IF SOMEBODY
HAS GOT TO MESS AROUND WITH THE
IRS THESE PEOPLE HAVE ALL THE
COURAGE IN THE WORLD.
YOUR THREE BOOKS RECEIVED A
LETTER FROM SOCIAL SECURITY IN
JUNE -- SAYING THAT THEY WERE
ADJUSTING HIS PAYMENTS BECAUSE
OF THE YOU KNOW HOW THEY
COMPUTER THINGS.
HE NEVER APPLIED FOR A PENSION.
SO HE CALL THEM AND THEY CHECKED
AND THEY WERE SENDING TWO
THOUSAND DOLLAR CHECKS EVERY
MONTH TO A BANK.
IN ATLANTA.
SO WHEN THEY CHECK THEIR BANK --
THE ACCOUNT HAD FIFTY DOLLARS
AND IT AT THAT POINT AND THAT
WAS IT.
AND THEN BUSH NEEDED HELP
ACTUALLY RIGHT ACROSS THE STREET
FROM.
FROM A SOCIAL SECURITY HE WAS SO
FRUSTRATED THEY TOLD ME TO TAKE
TWO YEARS TO STRAIGHTEN THAT OUT
AND DURING THAT TIME HE COULD
NOT APPLY FOR SOCIAL SECURITY HE
WALKED ACROSS THE JULIA
BROWNLEE'S OFFICE AND ASK FOR
THEIR HELP IN TRYING TO GET IT
STRAIGHTENED OUT. ONE PERSON.
THREE HUGE PROBLEMS AND THESE
ABSOLUTELY HAPPEN TO OWN HE HAS
A CLOUD ON IS OVER AS HEAD.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
HI EVERYBODY MY NAME IS JIM CASE --
I'M WITH BERKSHIRE HATHAWAY.
I AM NOW IN THE RISK MANAGEMENT
BUSINESS IN THE REAL ESTATE
BUSINESS -- THIS IS MY FORTY
FIFTH YOU'RE IN THE BUSINESS.
AND IT'S NOT QUITE THE SAME
TODAY AS IT WAS FORTY FIVE YEARS
AGO -- OBVIOUSLY THERE WAS NO
SUCH THING AS WIRE FRAUD BACK
THEN -- SEVERAL YEARS AGO THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS.
CAME OUT WITH THE FORM IT'S
CALLED A WIRE FRAUD ALERT --
IT'S PROBABLY BEEN AROUND FOR
ABOUT FIVE YEARS NOW MAYBE
[INAUDIBLE]
SIX AND WHEN I GOT IN THE
BUSINESS WHEN A PROPERTY CLOSED
ESCROW.
THERE MIGHT HAVE BEEN FIFTEEN
SIXTEEN PIECES OF PAPER IN THE
FILE.
THAT WAS ALL THAT WAS THERE --
THE PURCHASE AGREEMENT BACK THEN
WAS A SINGLE PAGE -- TODAY ONE
AN ESCROW CLOSES THERE PROBABLY.
RIGHT AROUND A HUNDRED AND FIFTY
PIECE OF PAPER IN THAT FILE --
SO IT'S QUITE A BIT DIFFERENT.
AND ONLY ONE OF THOSE PIECES OF
PAPER -- DEALS WITH WIRE FRAUD.
WHAT WE TEACH OUR PEOPLE AND I'M
SURE WHAT CHUCK DOES AS WELL?
IS THAT PARTICULAR FORM CANNOT
BE TREATED AS JUST ANOTHER PIECE
OF PAPER IN THE FILE.
THAT IS A FORM OF WHERE YOU WANT
TO HAVE A REAL CONVERSATION.
WITH.
YOUR CLIENT [INAUDIBLE]
ON ESCROW COMPANIES DO NOT
CHANGE BANK ACCOUNTS THEY DON'T
CHANGE WIRING INSTRUCTIONS.
IT DOESN'T I'VE BEEN VERY FOR
FORTY TWO YEARS TO AN ESCROW
OFFICER -- THERE ARE GOING TO BE.
EMAILS LEGITIMATE EMAILS GOING
OUT TOWARDS THE CLOSE OF AN
ESCROW INSTRUCTING PEOPLE TO
SEND THEIR MONEY TO SOMEWHERE
OTHER THAN.
THEY WERE TOLD OF THE VERY
BEGINNING OF THE TRANSACTION.
SO.
IT IS THE REALTORS
RESPONSIBILITY TO HAVE THAT
CONVERSATION WITH THEIR CLIENTS --
THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF TALK ABOUT --
MULTI FACTOR AUTHENTICATION.
OR AUTHORIZATION AND IT'S
SOMETHING IS REALLY NEEDED IN
THIS INDUSTRY -- TONY WALL FROM
THE DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S OFFICE
AND I HAVE SPENT A GREAT DEAL OF
TIME TALKING ABOUT THIS.
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT HOW.
TO OF MAKE IT SO THAT WOULD BE
KIND OF AN AUTOMATIC THING A
MANDATORY THING -- THAT'S NOT AN
EASY THING TO DO -- YOU -- I
KNOW JACQUI HAS WORKED WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS WITH OUR PEOPLE IN
SACRAMENTO -- I'M NOT SURE
WHETHER IT'S SOMETHING THAT --
CORD OR WILL BE LEGISLATED --
IT'S SOMETHING IT'S NEEDED IT'S
NOT SOMETHING THAT -- IS NOT
SOMETHING THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF REALTORS CAN DO
BECAUSE ALL REAL ESTATE
LICENSEES ARE NOT A MEMBER OF
THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS.
OF FOR EXAMPLE IN THE RIGHT HERE
IN CALIFORNIA THERE ARE TWO
HUNDRED AND AROUND TWO HUNDRED
ELEVEN THOUSAND MEMBERS OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS.
BUT THERE ARE ABOUT FOUR HUNDRED
AND TWENTY THOUSAND REAL ESTATE
LICENSEES ALL OF WHOM.
CAN SELL REAL ESTATE.
BUT THEY ARE NOT -- THEY'RE NOT
UNDER OPERATE UNDER THE AUSPICES
OF ALL OF THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF REALTORS.
IT'S A PROMISE ONE DISC THIS GOT
A MEETING AND IT'S NOT JUST THE
BIG IT'S IT'S NOT AS BIG DOLLAR
THINGS -- DO YOU HAVE THAT SLIDE.
OKAY -- THERE'S AN ORGANIZATION
HERE IN VENTURA -- INVENTOR
ACCOUNTING THOSE OF YOU IN THE
ROOM OR REALTORS I'VE HEARD OF
IT SOME OF YOU HAVE NOT.
IT'S CALLED REACH OUT THE REAL
ESTATE FRAUD ADVISORY TEAM.
ALL WE'VE BEEN IN EXISTENCE
SINCE -- TWO THOUSAND FIVE IT'S
A WONDERFUL PLACE TO GO FOR
RESOURCES WE HAVE CONTACT
INFORMATION FOR BASICALLY ALL
GOVERNMENTAL AGENCIES
CONTRACTORS LICENSE BOARD.
OF CALIFORNIA BAR ASSOCIATION IT
CETERA ETCETERA -- WE HAVE --
CONSUMER ALERTS UP THERE
BASICALLY EVERYTHING THAT HAS
BEEN PUT OUT BY THE VENTURA
COUNTY DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S
OFFICE.
BY THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
REAL ESTATE -- BY THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF REALTORS OF THE
ALL KINDS OF TIPS LIKE I SAID
ALL OF THE ALL CYBER CRIME IS
NOT IT'S NOT MAJOR STUFF.
OF THERE HAS BEEN GOING ON FOR
AT LEAST SEVEN OR EIGHT YEARS --
A FRAUD SO FAR AS RENTAL
PROPERTIES OF OUR OUR CONCERN --
SOMEBODY WILL TAKE -- THEY'LL
THEY'LL GO ON ZILLOW ORDER
REALTOR DOT COM OR SOME OR OR OR
SOMEPLACE LIKE THAT.
THEY WILL.
STILL THE PHOTOS OF THE HOME
THAT IS CURRENTLY ON THE MARKET
FOR SALE.
THEY WILL PUT IT ON CRAIG'S LIST
FOR RENT -- EVERY INCREDIBLE OF
AN INCREDIBLY REASONABLE RATE OF
RENT TYPICALLY ABOUT 50% OF WHAT
THE PROPERTY WOULD NORMALLY RENT.
FOR AND BASICALLY ADD WILL SAY
THE YOU KNOW THAT EITHER THEIR
THE TENANT THAT'S IN THERE
THEY'RE LEAVING -- FULL STORY
ABOUT THE PERSON -- WHO IS
MASQUERADING AS THE OWNER THAT
HE HAS SIGNED UP TO BE A
MISSIONARY SOMEPLACE IN A THIRD
WORLD COUNTRY FOR TWO YEARS HE
JUST WANTS SOMEBODY TO TAKE GOOD
CARE OF THE HOUSE -- THERE WAS A
CASE IN BODEGA BAY IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA THAT'S WERE ALFRED.
HITCHCOCK'S THE BIRDS WAS FELT
[INAUDIBLE] SIX FAMILIES.
OR RENTED THE SAME.
PROPERTY FOR A WEEK IN THE
SUMMERTIME.
THEY ALL SHOWED UP ON THE SAME
SUNDAY MORNING. TO MOVE IN FOR
THEIR WEEK SURVEY CATION -- THEY
ALL PAID UP FRONT WHICH YOU
NORMALLY DO WITH A THING LIKE
THAT.
SO SOMEBODY COLLECTED -- LIKE
THIRTY SOMETHING THOUSAND
DOLLARS FROM SIX DIFFERENT
FAMILIES IN THE PLACE WASN'T
EVEN AVAILABLE FOR RENT TO
ANYBODY.
SO OF ONE OF THE THINGS AND FOR
YOU REALTORS WITH THOSE OF YOU
ARE NOT ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
WE FOUND TO BE HELPFUL REAL
QUICKLY.
IS ONE OF OUR COLLATERAL PIECES.
IS THIS AND BASICALLY WHAT IT
SAYS IS WARNING THIS PROPERTY IS
NOT FOR RENT -- IT'S AVAILABLE
HONOR THE IS AVAILABLE ON OUR
WEBSITE ANY PROPERTY THAT'S ON
THE MARKET ESPECIALLY LIKE A
VACANT PROPERTY.
ALL WE HAVE OUR AGENTS PULL ONE
OF THESE OUR FRONT WINDOW.
SO SOMEBODY LOOKING AT THE HOUSE
JUST IN CASE IT DOES COME UP ON
CRAIG'S LIST FOR RENT -- THEY
WILL KNOW THAT THE PROPERTIES
NOT FOR RENT AND IT HAS THE
INFORMATION.
AS TO WHO TO CONTACT OF THE
FBI'S.
CYBER SITE IC THREE DOT GOV.
IS NOTATED ON AUG ON THE PAGE
THERE'S ALL KINDS OF GOOD STUFF
THERE -- YOU KNOW ONE OF THE
THINGS -- IF I HAVE ONE MORE
MINUTE ONE OF THE THINGS THAT I
THOUGHT ABOUT -- YOU'VE ALL
HEARD OF THE CONCEPT OF SIX
DEGREES OF SEPARATION RIGHT.
IT'S BEEN AROUND SINCE.
NINETEEN TWENTY NINE YOU KNOW
WHERE EVERYBODY THROUGH SIX OR
FEWER CONTACTS.
WOULD BE APPOINTED WITH
EVERYBODY ON THE FACE OF THE
PLANET.
OKAY WHAT WAS SOCIAL MEDIA NOW.
MAYBE IT'S FIVE DEGREES OF
SEPARATION MAYBE IT'S FOUR POINT
FIVE I DON'T KNOW.
YOUR FORTY MILLION PEOPLE
ROUGHLY IN CALIFORNIA -- MORE
THAN 80% OF THOSE PEOPLE ARE
HAVE INTERNET ACCESS.
AND MORE THAN 50% --
CONSIDERABLY MORE THAN 50% OR ON
FACEBOOK [INAUDIBLE]
SO.
WHAT I AM PROPOSING EVEN IN THE
SMALL ROOM LIKE THIS IS A SMALL
LITTLE SOCIAL EXPERIMENT?
IF YOU PICKED UP ANY TIDBITS
TODAY SO FAR AS WIRE FRAUD OR
WHATEVER.
FROM TONY OR KI<C.CYAN> OR WHATEVER.</C>
WHY NOT POST THAT?
ON YOUR FACEBOOK PAGE OR ON
TWITTER OR ANY PLACE ELSE WITH
THE HATCH HASH TAG THAT SAYS
SOMETHING LIKE.
HASHTAG STOP SCAMMERS SOMETHING
LIKE THAT.
AND SEND IT OUT TO ALL OF YOUR
ACQUAINTANCES ON WHATEVER SOCIAL
MEDIA NETWORK YOU USING WITH A
REQUEST THAT THEY SEND THAT.
TO EVERYBODY THEY KNOW NOW IT'S
NOT GOING TO BECOME VIRAL LIKE A
CUTE LITTLE PUPPY ON ON THE
INTERNET.
BUT IF WE SPREAD THE WORD IF WE
TRY TO SPREAD THE WORD AS MUCH
AS WE POSSIBLY CAN.
IF WE CAN STOP TWO ONE EVEN ONE
PERSON.
FROM MAKING THE MISTAKE OF
SENDING AWAY HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS OF THE
NEVER GOING TO SEE AGAIN.
WOULD BE WELL WORTH THE EFFORT.
AND I THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NANCY.
YES GOOD MORNING AND NANCY LYNN
HOME CEO THE OXNARD CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE -- WELL WE HAVE -- SOME
VERY LARGE VERY PROSPEROUS
BUSINESSES IN OXNARD THAT
PROVIDE.
THOUSANDS OF JOBS -- 85% OF OUR
MEMBERS AT THE ACTS ARE CHAMBER.
HAVE -- TWENTY FIVE EMPLOYEES OR
FEWER.
SO AS THE ASSEMBLY WOMAN STATED
THAT IN HER OPENING REMARKS A
SMALL BUSINESS CERTAINLY IS THE
BACKBONE OF OUR ECONOMY.
SOME AND WE SHOULD PROBABLY KNOW
THAT SMALL BUSINESSES DO NOT
HAVE SECURITY OR IT
PROFESSIONALS ON STAFF -- THEY
RELY ON OUTSIDE SERVICES TO
ADVISE AND PROTECT THEM -- AND
THE OX ARE CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
IS A SMALL BUSINESS WE HAVE
CONCERNS ABOUT THE DATA WE
COLLECT -- FROM OUR MEMBERS OUR
CUSTOMERS JUST AS ANY OTHER
SMALL BUSINESS WOULD
[INAUDIBLE]
I'M.
COMMUNICATING CYBERSECURITY BEST
PRACTICES TO SMALL BUSINESSES
IT'S CERTAINLY A CHALLENGE.
OF WERE ALL OVERWHELMED WITH.
BY INFORMATION THAT WE GET VIA
SOCIAL MEDIA.
ELECTRONIC NEWSLETTERS EMAILS --
AND GETTING AN IMPORTANT MESSAGE
OUT -- BEYOND ALL THE OTHER
NOISE IS SOMEWHAT DAUNTING -- WE
PUSH OUT A LOT OF WARNINGS TO
OUR MEMBERS AND THE BUSINESS
COMMUNITY.
ON ALL KINDS OF TOPICS SUCH AS
NEW LABOR LAWS PENDING
LEGISLATION.
CHANGES TO REGULATIONS LOCALLY --
HOWEVER WHEN IT COMES TO REALLY
CRITICAL ISSUES -- I KINDA GO
BACK IN TIME AND I PICK UP THE
PHONE -- IT'S IT'S IT'S A TIME
CONSUMING THING TO DO.
BUT SINCE MANY PEOPLE -- LET THE
EMAILS JUST PILE UP IN THE NEWS
LETTERS KIND OF GET FILED AWAY.
I HAVE A BETTER CHANCE OF REALLY
GETTING -- AN IMPORTANT MESSAGE
THROUGH A VIA A PHONE CALL.
AND OF COURSE THESE DAYS NOT
MANY PEOPLE COMMUNICATE VIA
PHONE SO THAT'S A LITTLE
CHALLENGING AS WELL -- AS FAR AS
COMMUNICATING THE BEST PRACTICES --
AND CYBERSECURITY I THINK WE
NEED.
TO REALLY RELY ON THE IT
COMPANIES TO COMMUNICATE WITH
THEIR SMALL BUSINESS CLIENTS.
I KNOW THAT'S PROBABLY SOMETHING
THEY WERE THERE THEY DO ON A
REGULAR BASIS BUT TO MAKE THEM
AWARE OF THESE SCAMS -- AND ALSO
WE HAVE A NEED TO LAUNCH A
COORDINATED COMMUNICATIONS PLAN.
TO EDUCATE SMALL BUSINESSES --
ON ALL OF THE CYBER THREATS THAT
WE CURRENTLY KNOW ABOUT AND
WE'RE HAPPY TO PARTICIPATE IN
THAT -- COORDINATED
COMMUNICATION EFFORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH [INAUDIBLE]
MR SURE.
WELL I'M GONNA FOLLOW UP ON THAT
BECAUSE THAT WAS -- VERY GOOD
AND I THINK -- WE CAN TAKE THAT
TAKE IT A STEP FURTHER NOW.
WHAT'S REALLY INTERESTING ABOUT
OUR DISCUSSIONS TODAY IS THAT.
WE'RE NOT REALLY TALKING ABOUT
HACKERS.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT SCAMMERS.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT PEOPLE WHO
DO SOCIAL ENGINEERING ATTACKS.
NOW WITH THE EXCEPTION OF THE
YOUNG WOMAN WHO TALKED ABOUT
HACKER ONE AND THE BROWNIES AND
ALL OF THAT STUFF AT THE END OF
THE DAY.
THE WAY THAT THESE PEOPLE ARE
GETTING.
IS BY TRICKING US.
RIGHT I MEAN THAT'S HOW WE'RE
GETTING TAKEN IS BECAUSE WE'RE
GETTING TRICKED.
AND SO THEN YOU ASK YOU SIR YOU
ASK YOURSELF THE QUESTION HOW DO
WE NOT GET TRICKED [INAUDIBLE]
RIGHT.
AND SO -- ACCORDING TO VERIZON'S
DATA BREACH INCIDENT REPORT
TWENTY EIGHTEEN THAT JUST CAME
OUT 93% [INAUDIBLE]
OF BREECHES ARE DUE TO HUMAN
ERROR.
OKAY.
AND SO LET'S FIGURE OUT A WAY TO
STOP HUMAN ERROR.
AND SECURITY WHERE IT'S IN
GENERAL LIKE IF YOU'RE GOING TO
A LARGER ORGANIZATION FIVE YEARS
AGO.
THEY WOULD SHOW YOU A FORTY FIVE
MINUTE LONG DEATH BY POWER POINT.
WE'RE ALL YOU WANTED TO DO IS GO
CLICK CLICK CLICK CLICK CLICK
CLICK CLICK AND GET TO THE VERY
END AS FAST AS YOU COULD.
RIGHT.
AND AT THE END OF THE DAY THAT
WAS A CHECK THE BOX EXERCISE FOR
THEM.
THAT REALLY DID NOTHING TO
EDUCATE THEIR EMPLOYEES ON
CYBERSECURITY -- BUT IT MEANT A
COMPLIANCE REQUIREMENTS
[INAUDIBLE]
DOESN'T WORK.
AND SO WE HAVE. THREE BIG
PROBLEMS.
THAT WE FACE IN THE
CYBERSECURITY TRAINING WORLD --
THAT NEED TO BE OVERCOME BY OUR
SECURITY AWARENESS PROGRAM RIGHT.
THE FIRST BIG PROBLEM IS THE
HUMAN ATTENTION SPAN IS DOWN 33%
FROM THE YEAR TWO THOUSAND TO
THE YEAR.
TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN THAT WAS A
MICROSOFT ADVERTISING STUDY THAT
THEY DID.
IT WOULD FROM EIGHT SECONDS TO
SIX SECONDS.
THE HUMAN ATTENTION SPAN OF A
CATERPILLARS EIGHT SECONDS.
OURS IS SIX WHAT DOES THAT MEAN.
IF WE ARE NOT ENGAGED.
IN WHATEVER IT IS THAT WE'RE
WATCHING THAT WE'RE LEARNING
THERE WERE HEARING ABOUT IN THE
FIRST SIX SECONDS.
WE'RE GONNA REMIND TO OUR MINDS
GO SOMEWHERE ELSE 90% OF THE
TIME WHERE THEY GO WE PICK UP
OUR FULL.
AND SEE JUST HOW MANY LIKE THREE
GOT IN OUR LAST INSTAGRAM POST.
RIGHT SEC THAT'S A HUGE PROBLEM
IS IT IS ATTENTION SPAN WHEN IT
COMES TO EDUCATING [INAUDIBLE]
OUR EMPLOYEES.
ON CYBER AWARENESS AND SO HOW DO
WE SOLVE FOR THAT.
WHAT WE SAW FOR THAT BY MAKING
THE TRAINING THAT WE DO FUN
ENGAGING AND INTERESTING RIGHT
AND SO WHAT I'M TALKING ABOUT
HERE IS SETTING UP? FOR FOR
SMALL BUSINESS TO SET UP OR HAVE.
EITHER ON YOUR OWN OR WITH THE
HELP OF A COMPANY LIKE US TO SET
UP A FULL FLEDGED SECURITY
AWARENESS PROGRAM FOR YOUR
EMPLOYEES.
ARM THE SECOND BIG PROBLEM IS
THAT HACKERS INNOVATE.
THERE ARE A MILLION NEW PIECES
OF MALWARE.
THAT ARE DEVELOPED.
NOT RELEASED OUT TO THE WORLD.
A MILLION NEW PIECES OF OUR THAT
ARE DEVELOPED EVERY DAY. TO
CRAZY STATISTIC.
AND THEN THE LAST -- ISSUE THAT
WE HAVE IS THAT.
WHEN WE DO CYBER AWARENESS
TRAINING A LOT OF ORGANIZATIONS
THEY DON'T HAVE FREQUENCY?
THEY DON'T HAVE CONSISTENCY.
RIGHT.
AND I'M GONNA GIVE YOU KIND OF A
CRUDE EXAMPLE OF WHAT I MEAN
HERE BY HOW HOW FREQUENCY IS
GONNA CURE CURIOSITY CURIOSITY.
IS ONE OF THE BIGGEST PROBLEMS
WE HAVE AS HUMANS.
AS WE GET THAT EMAIL THAT SAYS
WE JUST BEEN TAGGED ON FACEBOOK.
AND WE'RE CURIOUS WE'LL SEE WHAT
IT IS.
BUT IF YOU HOWEVER I HAVE I HAVE
OVER THE LINK CLEARLY IT DOESN'T
GO TO FACEBOOK WE DON'T TAKE THE
TIME TO LOOK AT IT WOULD SO WE
CLICK ON IT ANYWAY [INAUDIBLE]
RIGHT [INAUDIBLE]
AND SO.
CURIOSITY IS A BIG PROBLEM SO
HOW WE CURE CURIOSITY MATTEL
CRUDE STORY.
SO LET'S JUST SAY I GET HOME
TONIGHT FROM WORK.
AND I GET A CALL FROM MY WIFE
AND SHE'S CRYING.
AND I'M LIKE HONEY WHAT'S WRONG.
AND SHE SAYS WELL I JUST REAR
ENDED A YOUNG WOMAN IN FRONT OF
ME WERE BOTH OKAY I THINK I
TOTALED HER CAR -- WE'RE BOTH
FIND THAT I'M REALLY SHAKEN UP
RIGHT NOW.
A CIVIL WHAT HAPPENED.
AND SHE SAID WELL I'M SUPPOSED
TO MEET MY GIRLFRIENDS FOR
DINNER TOMORROW NIGHT I FELT --
A BUZZ GO OFF IN MY PURSE -- IS
ON THE FLOOR I REACH DOWN TO
GRAB MY PHONE IS BANNED.
REREAD THAT PERSON.
AND SHE OBVIOUSLY AS SHE
SHOULDN'T BE TEXTING AND DRIVING
RIGHT.
SO THE NEXT DAY COMES I'M ON MY
WAY TO WORK.
I'M WAITING FOR THIS REALLY BIG
DEAL TO COME THROUGH.
MY PHONE WAS OFF IN MY POCKET.
I'M ABOUT TO REACH FOR IT
[INAUDIBLE]
I DON'T [INAUDIBLE]
WHY?
BECAUSE OF THE STORY THAT I
HEARD FROM MY WIFE LAST NIGHT.
THE PROXIMITY OF THE EVENT.
CHANGED MY HUMAN BEHAVIOR.
OKAY. SIX MONTHS GO BY.
INSURANCE IS TAKING CARE OF
EVERYTHING EVERYTHING'S COOL.
I GET A BUZZ IN MY POCKET.
UPON MY PHONE OUT AND I LOOK AT
IT.
BECAUSE NOW THAT EVENT IS IN THE
BACK OF MY BRAIN.
MY WHOLE POINT HERE IS THAT.
EMPLOYERS SMALL BUSINESSES.
NEED TO SET UP A PROGRAM.
THAT HAS FREQUENCY WHERE YOU'RE
TOUCHING YOUR USERS AT LEAST
THREE TIMES A MONTH.
WITH SOMETHING.
THAT IS ABOUT SECURITY AWARENESS.
AND IS SOMETHING THAT IS
ENGAGING AND IS GOING TO GET
THEIR ATTENTION.
RIGHT WE DON'T WANT PEOPLE
RUNNING AROUND -- PARANOID.
BUT WE DO WANT OUR EMPLOYEES
RUNNING AROUND WITH THEIR
ANTENNAS UP.
THE RADAR GOING.
SO THAT THEY ARE A LOT MORE
CAREFUL.
WHEN THEY'RE SITTING IN FRONT OF
THEIR PC?
IT THE END OF THE DAY.
WHAT WE REALLY WANT TO DO IS
CREATE A CULTURE?
OF SECURITY AWARENESS WITHIN OUR
ORGANIZATION. ONE OF THE WAYS
THAT WE DO IT NGO AND I'M GONNA
OFFER THIS AT THE EVERYONE IN
THE AUDIENCE HERE.
IS WE HAVE A PROGRAM CALLED
FAMILY USE RIGHTS.
AND SO WHEN YOU'RE SUBSCRIBER TO
OUR PLATFORM.
YOU CAN ADD UP TO FIVE FAMILY
MEMBERS TO RECEIVE OUR VIDEOS
THAT VIDEO YOU SAW WE DO ONE OF
THOSE EVERY THIRTY DAYS.
AND SO YOU CAN -- SUBSCRIBER FOR
UP TO FIVE FAMILY MEMBERS TO
RECEIVE THIS VIDEO AS WELL.
SO NOW THE SPOUSE COMES HOME.
FROM WORK SITTING AROUND THE
DINNER TABLE.
THE YES SIGN EPISODE ON A
WATERING HOLE ATTACK ON MALVERN
TIES SING OR AND KEYSTROKE
LOGGING RIGHT WE'VE GOT ALL OF
THOSE EPISODES COVER.
AND THEY HAVE A CONVERSATION
ABOUT IT.
AND WHAT HAPPENS IS.
YOU'VE NOW STARTED THAT
CONVERSATION WITHIN THE FAMILY
UNIT.
OF SECURITY AWARENESS AND
CREATING A SECURITY AWARE
CULTURE WITHIN THE FAMILY
BECAUSE AT THE END OF THE DAY
THINK ABOUT IT WE GET HACKED AT
WORK.
WITH RANSOMWARE WORK WE GET
RANSOMWARE HOME WE GET FISH TO
WORK WE GET FISHED AT HOME RIGHT.
EVERYONE OF THESE BREACHES
HAPPENS IN BOTH PLACES.
IN THIS PEOPLE HAVE MENTIONED IT
HOME.
WE ARE -- IN A LOT MORE OF A
DIRE SITUATION BECAUSE WE DON'T
HAVE AS MANY BLINKING LIGHTS IN
THE DATA CENTER THAT WE DO IT
WORK.
THERE ARE YOU KNOW PIECES OF
SOFTWARE AND HARDWARE TO PROTECT
OURSELVES.
SO GETTING EMPLOYEES TO MAKE A
PARADIGM SHIFT.
THAT THE SECURITY AWARENESS
TRAINING THAT THEY GET.
SURE IT'S DELIVERED BY THEIR
EMPLOYER TO PROTECT THEIR
EMPLOYER BUT AT THE END OF THE
DAY WHAT YOU REALLY WANT IS YOUR
EMPLOYEE TO TAKE A PERSONAL
ATTACHMENT. TO BEING SECURITY
WHERE.
BECAUSE THEY CAN VAN -- VIEW
SECURITY AWARENESS TRAINING FROM
YOUR ORGANIZATION AS AN EMPLOYEE
BENEFIT.
IS A FOUR MINUTE BREAK OUT OF
THEIR WORK DAY.
AND ONCE THAT PARADIGM SHIFT IS
HAPPENING THAT EMPLOYEE THE
SECURITY OF YOUR ORGANIZATION
GOES UP.
EXPONENTIALLY.
BECAUSE NOW THEY'RE PROTECTING
THEMSELVES THEY'RE PROTECTING
THEIR FAMILIES THEY'RE
PROTECTING THEIR ORGANIZATIONS.
AS OF I CAN JUST LEAVE YOU WITH
YOU KNOW A FEW THOUGHTS.
EVERY ORGANIZATION ON THE PLANET
I DON'T CARE IF YOU'RE THREE
PEOPLE.
ARE FIVE PEOPLE.
YOU NEED A FORMAL SECURITY
AWARENESS TRAINING PROGRAM IN
PLACE.
IT NEEDS TO BE FUN AND EDUCATING
THE SAME TIME IT NEEDS TO BE
SERIOUS.
IT NEEDS TO HAVE FREQUENCY.
SO THE PEOPLE ARE CONSTANTLY
REINFORCED ON WHAT THEY'RE BEING
TAUGHT.
BECAUSE IF YOU DO IT ONCE IN
OCTOBER IN SECURITY AWARENESS
MONTH AND THEN YOU DON'T TOUCH
IT AGAIN UNTIL FEBRUARY.
FORGET ABOUT IT SECOND WORK.
SO THAT'S A I GUESS MY WORDS OF
WISDOM -- FOR THE DAY.
OUT.
MY EMAIL ADDRESS IF IF ANYBODY
WANTS TO WRITE IT DOWN.
IT'S PRETTY SIMPLE IT'S ZACK Z.
A C. K..
AT NINJA O. N. I. N. J. I. O.
DOT COM.
IF YOU SEND ME AN EMAIL AND JUST
SAY.
I SAW YOU AT THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS -- WOULD RECALLING THIS
INFORMATIONAL HEARING.
PLEASE ADD ME TO FAMILY USE
RIGHTS.
I WILL ADD YOU.
YOU WILL ALL GET ONE OF OUR
EPISODE EVERY THIRTY DAYS AT NO
COST.
JUST FOR YOU AT LEAST SECOND.
GIVE EVERYBODY IN THE AUDIENCE
HERE SOMETHING.
I THOUGHT GOT THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU AND AND THIS WAS
AGAIN VERY INFORMATIVE AND AND
ZACH I LOVE HOW PASSIONATE YOU
ARE ABOUT TO MAKING SURE WE ALL
STAY SAFE AND JUST TO EMPHASIZE
AGAIN WITH ALL OF YOU IN YOUR
ORGANIZATIONS WHETHER IT'S THREE
OR THREE THOUSAND PEOPLE.
THE EMPLOYEES IN YOUR
ORGANIZATION ARE ALWAYS THE WEAK
LINK SO.
THE REGULAR TRAINING THE REGULAR
TOUCHES IS SOMETHING THAT WILL
DEFINITELY -- KEEP YOUR BUSINESS
MORE SECURE SO -- CAN WE HAVE A
ROUND OF APPLAUSE FOR OUR SECOND
PANEL PLEASE.
AND NOW FOR OUR LAST PANEL --
AND WE REALLY APPRECIATE THEM
FLYING IN WE ARE GOING TO TALK
ABOUT THE CYBER SECURITY BEST
PRACTICES FOR SMALL BUSINESSES.
AND PROFESSIONALS AND THEIR SO --
YOU GUYS ARE READY M. SEATED
WITH US TO HEAR HERE TODAY.
TO ANSWER QUESTIONS THAT YOU
HOPEFULLY ANSWER THE QUESTIONS
YOU HAVE AS A KNOWLEDGEABLE
PANEL FROM LEADING COMPANIES IN
THE CYBERSECURITY SPACE.
I WOULD LIKE TO WELCOME DAVID
KOHLBERG WHO IS THE SENIOR
DIRECTOR OF GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS --
FOR PALO ALTO NETWORKS AND ROB
SYDELL SKI WHO IS THE TRUST AND
SECURITY LEAD FOR GOOGLE CLOUD
WELCOME GENTLEMEN THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR JOINING US HERE IN
VENTURA COUNTY [INAUDIBLE]
THANK YOU [INAUDIBLE]
BROUGH [INAUDIBLE]
OKAY -- GREAT -- GOOD MORNING
AND AND THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY -- TO TO
SPEAK TO THE ASSEMBLY HERE -- MY
NAME'S ROB SAID OWSKI -- AS HE
SAID I AM THE TRUST AND SECURITY
LEAD FOR GOOGLE CLOUD A GOOGLE
WHERE I WORK WITH OUR PRODUCT
TEAMS WHO DEVELOP SECURITY
PRODUCTS AND RUN GOOGLE SERVICES
THAT HELP BUSINESSES PROTECT
THEIR USERS.
THEIR SENSITIVE DATA IN THEIR
APPLICATIONS -- OF WORKING
INFORMATION SECURITY FOR THE
PAST FIFTEEN YEARS INCLUDING
SERVING ON THE PAYMENT CARD
INDUSTRY SECURITY STANDARDS
COUNCIL BOARD OF ADVISORS WHERE
I GOT TO SEE.
IN SHAPE A LOT OF FIRST HAND THE
REGULATIONS TO PROTECT CREDIT
CARD DATA -- HERE IN THE US AND
ABROAD WHICH IS A MAJOR FOCUS AS
WE'VE SEEN OUR CYBER CRIMINAL
ACTIVITY AND SOURCE OF DATA
BREACHES.
AND WHILE THE CYBER THREAT
LANDSCAPE CONTINUES TO GROW AND
EVOLVE AND PRESENT NEW
CHALLENGES FOR CONSUMERS AND
BUSINESSES ALIKE.
BUSINESSES OF EVERY SIZE HAVE
NEVER HAD ACCESS TO THE TOOLS
AND CAPABILITIES AND
TECHNOLOGIES AND EXPERTISE TO
HELP THEM DEAL WITH THE BUSINESS
CHALLENGE OF CYBER SECURITY.
AS THEY DO TODAY AND THAT'LL BE
THE FOCUS OF MY REMARKS THE BEST
PRACTICES AND CAPABILITIES THAT
TODAY'S BUSINESSES IN CALIFORNIA
AND ELSEWHERE LARGE AND SMALL.
CAN ADOPT TO HELP MAKE THEM MORE
RESILIENT IN THE FACE OF
CYBERCRIME AND CYBER THREATS --
TO HAVE MY MY VISUALS -- OKAY --
THINGS WERE FINE [INAUDIBLE]
BOB PROGRAM [INAUDIBLE]
OKAY.
YOU KNOW WHAT YOU WANT ME TO GO
YEAH WHY DON'T YOU GO YES THAT
WOULD BE GREAT AT SIX DOLLARS A
TIME FOR A WHILE WE'RE LOOKING.
FOR SURE -- TO MANAGER THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TODAY -- TO
PURE BEFORE YOU DISCUSS THE
POLICIES PARTNERSHIPS AND
TECHNOLOGY INNOVATIONS --
ENABLING THE CYBERSECURITY OF
THE SMALL BUSINESS COMMUNITY.
ORDER FIRST THANK YOU FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE.
AND OFFER OUR COMMITMENT TO WORK
IN PARTNERSHIP WITH YOU AND YOUR
STAFF TO SUPPORT THE COMMITTEE'S.
OVERSIGHT RESPONSIBILITIES -- WE
COLLECTIVELY SEEK TO BOLSTER
CALIFORNIA'S ENTER NATION
SECURITY POSTURE.
MY COMMENTS TODAY ARE DESIGNED
TO HELP IMPROVE SMALL BUSINESSES
ABILITY DEFEND AGAINST
INCREASINGLY AGILE.
AND SOPHISTICATED CYBER THREATS
BY OUTLINING OUR APPROACH TO
PREVENTION.
IN REVIEWING SOME OF THE KEY
INITIATIVES AIMED AT IMPROVING
THE OVERALL SECURITY POSTURE OF
THE SMALL BUSINESS COMMUNITY.
FOR EXPAND ON THESE KEY POINTS A
LIKE TO BRIEFLY INTRODUCE MYSELF
IN THE COMPANY AND PRIVILEGED TO
REPRESENT -- AS YOU STATED MY
NAME IS DAVID COLE OVER AGAIN
I'VE SERVED AS POWER TO NETWORK
SENIOR DIRECTOR FOR GOVERNMENT
AFFAIRS FOR NEARLY THREE YEARS.
IN THIS ROLE I BUILD STRATEGIC
PARTNERSHIPS AND DRY POLICY
DEVELOPMENT ALIGNED WITH CALL TO
NETWORKS MISSION. TO MAKE THE
WORLD A SAFER EACH DAY.
BY PROTECTING OUR DIGITAL WAY OF
LIFE.
A PRIOR TO JOINING PALO ALTO
NETWORKS A CERTAIN NUMBER OF
POLICY ROLES ACROSS INDUSTRY AND
ALSO HAD THE HONOR.
OF SERVING FOR NEARLY A DECADE
UNITED STATES NAVY.
PRIMARILY AS A NAVAL FLIGHT
OFFICER -- BUT WITH MY LAST
ASSIGNMENT AS A SIGNATURE THE
NAVY'S LIAISON OFFICER TO
CONGRESS.
ALL THE NETWORKS WAS FOUNDED TWO
THOUSAND FIVE IN ESSENCE BECOME
THE WORLD'S LEADING
CYBERSECURITY COMPANY.
EMPOWERING OVER SIXTY THOUSAND
AND PRICE CUSTOMERS ACROSS ALL
SECTORS IN OVER A HUNDRED FIFTY
COUNTRIES WORLDWIDE.
OUR CUSTOMERS AND PARTNERS
ACROSS THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
REGARDLESS OF SIZE OR SECTOR.
FIND THEMSELVES AT VARIOUS
STAGES OF A OF A DIGITAL
TRANSFORMATION JOURNEY. FOR SOME
DIGITAL TRANSFORMATION MEANS
LEVERAGING CLOUD CAPABILITIES TO
IMPROVE OPERATIONAL COST
EFFICIENCIES. FOR OTHERS
ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE AND
MACHINE LEARNING ARE CRITICAL
THE HARNESSING THE POWER AND
VALUE OF AN ORGANIZATION'S DATA.
TO ENHANCE BUSINESS PROCESSES OR
IMPROVE ON THINGS LIKE CUSTOMER
SERVICE.
WHILE INNOVATIONS EMERGING
TECHNOLOGIES LIKE CLOUD A I AND
MACHINE LEARNING PRESENTS
SIGNIFICANT OPPORTUNITIES THE
ALSO INTERNED INTRODUCED
SIGNIFICANT RISK.
IN OTHER WORDS DIGITAL
TRANSFORMATION CANNOT OCCUR
WITHOUT A PARALLEL SECURITY
TRANSFORMATION.
AND IT'S CRITICAL FOR
POLICYMAKERS AND BOTH GOVERNMENT
INDUSTRY LEADERS. TO UNDERSTAND
THEIR ABILITY TO IMPACT THE
SECURITY ELEMENTS OF THIS
JOURNEY.
ACHIEVING AN EFFECTIVE SECURITY
TRANSFORMATION REQUIRES BOTH A
STRONG UNDERSTANDING OF THE
CURRENT THREAT ENVIRONMENT.
AS WELL AS A CLEAR VISION FOR
EMPLOYING THE PEOPLE PROCESSES
AND TECHNOLOGY ORIA ORIENTED
STRATEGIES.
THAT CAN BE LEVERAGED TO
MITIGATE THESE THREATS.
THE NATURE OF THE THREAT WE FACE
TODAY CAN MOST EASILY BE
DESCRIBED AS A MATH BATTLE.
COST OF COMPUTE HAS RAPID IT HAS
BEEN RAPIDLY DECLINING ALLOWING
OUR ADVERSARIES TO LAUNCH
INCREASINGLY AUTOMATED.
AND SOPHISTICATED ATTACKS AT
MINIMAL COST.
IN THE FACE OF THIS AUTOMATED
ONSLAUGHT THE NETWORK DEFENDER
IS GENERALLY RELYING ON LEGACY
SECURITY TECHNOLOGIES.
OFTEN COBBLE TOGETHER AS
MULTIPLE LAYERS OF POINT
PRODUCTS THAT'S ALL DISCRETE
PROBLEMS.
BUT DO NOT ENTER OPERATE AT THE
LEVEL NEEDED TO COUNTER THE
THREAT.
THIS COMPLEXITY CREATES A
DEPENDENCE ON PEOPLE THE LEAST
SCALABLE RESOURCE IN ANY
ORGANIZATION. TO MANUALLY DEFEND
AGAINST AUTOMATED MACHINE
GENERATED THE TAX.
THE BOTTOM LINE IS THE GOOD GUYS
ARE LOSING THEM OUT THAT'LL.
LARGELY BECAUSE WE'RE BRINGING
PEOPLE TO A SOFTWARE FIGHT.
WELL INNOVATION IS CORNERSTONE
TO ANY SUCCESSFUL BUSINESS
STRATEGY.
WE ALSO IDENTIFIED HOW IT CAN
ADD COMPLEXITY TO YOUR OVERALL
RISK MANAGEMENT STRATEGY.
WITH THIS IN MIND -- LIKE TO
DIVE A LITTLE DEEPER INTO HOW WE
MAY IMPROVE EXISTING BEST
PRACTICES AROUND INFORMATION
SHARING.
AND DRIVE MORE EFFECTIVE RISK
MANAGEMENT INTO THE ADOPTION OF
NEW TECHNOLOGIES. ONE SUCH
PRACTICE AND A FUNDAMENTAL
CHALLENGE FACING SMALL AND LARGE
BUSINESSES ALIKE.
HE'S KEEPING PACE WITH THE
LATEST CYBER THREATS THROUGH
INFORMATION SHARING PROGRAMS.
THE GOOD NEWS IS THAT ROBUST
AUTOMATED SHARING PROGRAMS EXIST.
YOUR NONPROFIT ENTITIES LIKE THE
CYBER THREAT ALLIANCE WERE
CYBERSECURITY VENDORS ARE
COOPERATING TO WIDELY AND
AUTOMATICALLY DISTRIBUTE THREAT
PROTECTIONS.
DOWN TO SMALL BUSINESS LEVEL.
WE'RE PROUD TO BE A FOUNDING
MEMBER OF THE CYBER THREAT
ALLIANCE AND AND NOW INCLUDES
TWENTY FOUR MEMBER COMPANIES
INCLUDING THE SIX LARGEST
CYBERSECURITY VENDORS IN THE
WORLD.
THE UNDERLYING CHALLENGE WITH
SHARING THREAT INTELLIGENCE
UNIQUE TO THE SECURITY SECTOR.
IS THAT MANY CYBERSECURITY
COMPANIES CONTINUE TO BE YOU
CYBER THREAT INTELLIGENCE AS
INTELLECTUAL PROPERTY.
SO INSTEAD OF SHARING THIS
CRITICAL DATA FREELY AND OPENLY.
MANY STILL MARKET THE STATE AS
PART OF A SALES STRATEGY.
OUR COMPANY STANCE IS QUITE
SIMPLE.
YOU SHOULD COMPETE ON WHAT YOUR
TECHNOLOGY DOES WITH CYBER
THREAT INFORMATION RATHER THAN
THE INFORMATION ITSELF. ONE EASY
METHOD FOR GOVERNMENTS TO
INCENTIVIZE EFFECTIVE
INFORMATION SHARING IS TO SIMPLY
ASK BUSINESSES SEEKING CONTRACTS
IF THEY ARE MEMBERS OF THE CTA
OR ANY ORGANIZATION LIKE IT.
AND IF NOT WHY NOT.
AND FINALLY WE MUST ALSO KEEP
PACE WITH THE SECURITY
IMPLICATIONS OF NEW
INFRASTRUCTURE DESIGNS TO
INCLUDE NEW CAPABILITIES LIKE
NEXT GEN.
NINE ONE ONE AND SMART CITIES.
AND THE RAPID ADOPTION OF NEW
TECHNOLOGIES LIKE FIVE G.. FOR
EXAMPLE FIVE G. WILL INCREASE
SPEED REDUCE LATENCY AND ALLOWS
TO SIGNIFICANTLY RAMP UP WHAT
RIGHTS ON OUR NETWORKS.
A TRADITIONAL BREACH WITH THE
NORMAL AND NORMALLY ANTICIPATED
INFILTRATION OF PRIVACY WILL NOW
INCLUDE PHYSICAL RISKS AND
CONSEQUENCES.
ON A MUCH GREATER SKILL.
WE CAN'T MAKE THE SAME MISTAKES
WE MADE IN THE PAST AND HOPE THE
SLAPPING SECURITY ON AS AN
AFTERTHOUGHT WILL SUFFICE.
THIS IS POTENTIALLY AN AREA OF
WHERE THE ASSEMBLY COULD
CONSIDER ACTION -- OVERSIGHT TO
ASSIST THE PROMISE OF FIVE G.
ACCELERATING THE DEVELOPMENT OF
SMART CITIES CONNECTED CARS
MEDICAL DEVICES I TEAM MORE.
LEGISLATORS SHOULD BE AWARE THAT
WHAT FIVE G. OPENS THE DOOR TO
EXCITING NEW BUSINESS
OPPORTUNITIES IT ALSO INCREASES
THE NUMBER OF POTENTIAL
INTRUSION POINTS.
AMPLIFYING THE SECURITY CONCERNS.
MEDIC TO MITIGATE THE INCREASED
RISK ASSOCIATED WITH FIVE G. WE
MUST ENCOURAGE
TELECOMMUNICATIONS PROVIDERS TO
ENSURE COMPLETE VISIBILITY AN
AUTOMATED SECURITY.
ACROSS ALL NETWORK LOCATIONS.
THE SERVER ENVIRONMENT A RISING
TIDE TRULY LIFTS ALL BOATS.
SO WE'RE ON THE SAME BOAT
TOGETHER.
MADAM CHAIR THANK YOU AGAIN FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY TODAY
AND I WOULD FORTY ANSWERING
QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
OF THE AND WE'LL SEE IF THERE'S
TIME FOR QUESTIONS AT THE END
BUT IT IS A THEY ARE WE WE WERE
RIGHT ON TO ICLOUD RIGHT.
YES HOPEFULLY GOOGLE CLOUD --
FIVE YES GREAT.
AND COMMUTE TO THE NEXT SLIDE
PLEASE.
GREAT -- SO THANK YOU FOR BEING
WITH US ON ON SO I KEEP GETTING
THIS READY -- SO TO TO JUMP BACK
IN SMALL BUSINESSES LEVERAGE
YOU'LL TO GROW TO STAY SECURE
AND SAVE TIME AND MONEY SO NOT
ONLY DO THEY TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
OUR TOOLS TO COMMUNICATE TO
REACH CUSTOMERS BUT INCREASINGLY.
THEY DEPEND ON CLOUD SOFTWARE
PROVIDERS LIKE GOOGLE AND OTHERS
TO HELP THEM PROTECT THEIR
BUSINESS.
AND RATHER THAN HIRING EXPERTS
OR BECOMING EXPERT THEMSELVES
BOTH YOU VERY BIG CHALLENGES
BECAUSE OF THE INDUSTRY WIDE
SHORTAGE OF CYBER SECURITY
SKILLS AND WORKERS AND A WHAT
WOULD BE CONSIDERABLE EXPENSE.
THEY RELY ON THE EXPERTISE THE
PROTECTION AND POWERFUL SECURITY
CAPABILITIES THAT WE AND OTHER
PROVIDERS OF BUILT INTO OUR
PRODUCTS.
IN OUR NEXT SLIDE PLEASE THEY
NEED TO BECAUSE AS WE'VE HEARD
ALREADY SECURITY THREATS TARGET
BUSINESSES OF ALL SIZES BUT
OFTEN DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACT
SMALL BUSINESSES NO THE RESEARCH
SHOWS IN WITH THIS IS BEEN CITED
BY PREVIOUS.
PRESENTERS THAT -- SIGNIFICANT
GROWTH OF BREACHES TARGETING
SMALL BUSINESSES SPECIFICALLY
WHEN YOU COUPLE THIS WITH THE
FACT THAT WE HEARD EARLIER THAT
ALMOST HALF A SMALL BUSINESSES
WOULD EXPECT TO CLOSE
PERMANENTLY AFTER A DATA BREACH.
THIS HAS SIGNIFICANT
CONSEQUENCES ON BOTH OUR
ECONOMIES IN PEOPLE'S
LIVELIHOODS I ALSO WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT THE IF -- THE FACT
THAT THE TOOL USED BY ALMOST
EVERY SMALL BUSINESS FOR
COMMUNICATING WITH EMPLOYEES AND
CUSTOMERS EMAIL IS THE MOST
COMMON WAY CYBER ATTACKS START
SO WE CLEARLY NEED SOLUTIONS.
OUR NEXT SLIDE PLEASE.
GOOGLE IS HEAVILY INVESTED IN
STOPPING THIS MALICIOUS ACTIVITY
PROTECTING USERS IN MAKING THE
INTERNET SAFER FOR EVERYONE IN
OUR SYSTEMS AND PRODUCTS.
SO -- GOOGLE STOPS ON THE ORDER
OF TEN MILLION SPAM AND
MALICIOUS EMAILS A MINUTE ACROSS
ALL OF OUR DIFFERENT PRODUCTS
AND SERVICES.
WE SKIN ALMOST SEVEN HUNDRED
THOUSAND WEB PAGES EVERY MINUTE
FOR SIGNS OF MALICIOUS INTENT
LIKE FISHING OR DISTRIBUTION OF
MALWARE.
WE PROTECT OVER A BILLION EMAIL
ACCOUNTS AND CHECK FOUR HUNDRED
BILLION ANDROID DEVICES A DAY
FOR MALICIOUS SOFTWARE.
AGAIN HELP THE USERS OF THOSE
SERVICES AND WE ENCRYPT CUSTOMER
DATA AT REST AND IN TRANSIT TO
HELP PROTECTED FROM UNAUTHORIZED
ACCESS.
AND WHILE ALL THESE PROTECTIONS
ARE HELPFUL.
AS WE'VE HEARD BUSINESSES MUST
ALSO PLAY AN ACTIVE ROLE THEY
KNOW THAT THEIR PEOPLE AND DATA
AND BUSINESS PROCESSES THEY KNOW
THIS IS THE BEST AND THEY'RE IN
THE BEST POSITION TO MAKE THE
INFORM SECURITY CHOICES AND
DECISIONS.
THE MATCH UP WITH THEIR BUSINESS
NEEDS UNFORTUNATELY PROVIDERS
LIKE GOOGLE OFFER VERY POWERFUL
IN EASY TO USE SECURITY TOOLS TO
HELP BUSINESSES DO THEIR PART.
NEXT SLIDE PLEASE.
AND WHILE EVERY BUSINESS IS
DIFFERENT FOCUSING ON THE MOST
COMMON THREATS MANY OF WHICH
WE'VE HEARD ABOUT TODAY AND THE
MOST EFFECTIVE PROTECTIONS CAN
HAVE THE MOST IMPACT.
WE BELIEVE THAT SMALL BUSINESSES
SHOULD TRY TO FIRST PROTECT
AGAINST EMAIL BORNE THREATS
WE'VE HEARD SO MUCH ABOUT THIS
BEING THE MOST COMMON THREAT
FACTOR.
SECOND THE SHOULD STE REALLY
WORK ON STRENGTHENING PROTECTION
FOR THEIR HIGH VALUE USERS THEIR
EXECUTIVES THERE FINANCE
PERSONNEL THEIR I. T. ADMINS
WITH A LOT OF CONTROL IMPACT
OVER WHAT HAPPENS.
IN THE BUSINESS AND I'LL WELCOME
A COMPROMISE WOULD BE VERY
SERIOUS.
THIRD THEY NEED TO FOCUS ON
WHERE THEY'RE SENSITIVE BUSINESS
DAY.
AND THIS MIGHT BE PERSONAL DATA
ON CUSTOMERS OR EMPLOYEES IT
COULD BE PAYMENT DATE IT COULD
BE HEALTH DATA IT COULD BE LEGAL
INFORMATION.
AND PROACTIVELY LIMIT THE ON OFF
THE RICE HEARING OR ACCESS OF
THIS INFORMATION TO PROCESS SEES
IN TECHNOLOGY.
AND FINALLY AS WE HEARD VERY
ELOQUENTLY IN THE LAST
PRESENTATION.
BUSINESSES MUST ACKNOWLEDGE AND
MAKE SECURITY A BUSINESS
PRIORITY THEY NEED TO HELP THEIR
EMPLOYEES UNDERSTAND THAT THEY
ARE THE FRONTLINE OF DEFENSE --
FOR THEIR BUSINESSES AND TAKE
THIS SERIOUSLY SO I'D LIKE TO
SPEND A LITTLE TIME ON EACH OF
THESE AND DISCUSS HOW CLOUT
TECHNOLOGY FOR PROVIDERS LIKE
GOOGLE AND OTHERS CAN HELP.
NEXT SLIDE PLEASE.
SO LET'S START WITH EMAIL BORNE
THREATS AS WE'VE HEARD FISHING
ATTACKS OR EMAILS THAT
IMPERSONATE A TRUSTED SOURCE TO
TRICK USERS INTO SHARING
INFORMATION OR INSTALLING
MALICIOUS SOFTWARE.
IS A VERY PERVASIVE PROBLEM.
AND LIKE MANY SECURITY
CHALLENGES DEFENDING AGAINST
PHISHING ATTACKS REQUIRES
MULTIPLE LAYERS OF DEFENSE A
CONCEPT OF WHAT WE CALL SECURITY
DEFENSE IN DEPTH.
NOW THE IDEAL DEFENSE IS
STOPPING FISHING EMAILS FROM
EVER REACHING A USER'S INBOX IF
WE CAN DO THAT.
IT'S A VERY VERY STRONG
PROTECTION BUT THIS REQUIRES
SMART SOFTWARE TO FILTER OUT THE
DANGEROUS EMAILS BUT LET
LEGITIMATE EMAILS THROUGH SO
THAT THE BUSINESS IS NOT
AFFECTED.
STRIKING THIS BALANCE IS
DIFFICULT IN EVIL PROVIDERS LIKE
GOOGLE HAVE A LOT OF EXPERIENCE
IN TECHNOLOGY TO HELP.
WE BLOCK MORE THAN NINETY NINE
POINT 9% OF SPAM PHISHING AND
MALWARE FOR ME FROM REACHING
EMAIL INBOXES OF THE USE OF THE
SERVICES CAN REALLY HELP.
THE SMALL BUSINESSES.
THE NEXT LINE OF DEFENSE IS
STOPPING USES FROM CLICKING ON
THESE MALICIOUS LINKS THAT WE'VE
SEEN EXAMPLES OF IF AN EMAIL
DOES GET THROUGH.
WE OFFER A TECHNOLOGY CALLED
GOOGLE SAFE BROWSING THAT WORKS
ACROSS OUR PRODUCTS IN POWER SEE
FOR BROWSING EXPERIENCES ACROSS
THE INTERNET.
GOOGLE SAFE BROWSING HELPS
PROTECT OVER THREE BILLION
DEVICES EVERY DAY BY SHOWING
WARNINGS TO USERS WHEN THEY
ATTEMPT TO NAVIGATE TO WHAT WE
CONSIDER DANGEROUS SITES OR
DOWNLOAD DANGEROUS FILES.
WHEN YOU SEE THIS FLASHING RED
WARNING GENERALLY YOU STOP RIGHT --
SAFE BROWSING ALSO NOTIFIES THE
WEBMASTERS THE PEOPLE CONTROL
WEB PRESENCES WHEN THEIR
WEBSITES MAY BE COMPROMISED IN
SO IT HELPS THEM DIAGNOSE AND
RESOLVE THE PROBLEM SO THERE
VISITORS TO COME TO THEIR SITES
AND COMES TO THEIR BUSINESS.
CAN STAY SAFER.
NEXT SLIDE PLEASE.
IN VERY RARE INSTANCES WE'VE
ALSO HEARD THE GOVERNMENT BACKED
ATTACKERS MAY BE NEW TRY TO
COMPROMISE USER ACCOUNTS.
G. EMAIL CAN EVEN DEFECT --
DETECT THESE TYPE OF ATTACKS AND
WARM BUSINESSES OF SUCH A
SERIOUS SITUATION HERE WE HAVE
AN EXAMPLE OF HOW WE WOULD DO
THAT -- IN OUR SOFTWARE.
BACKSIDE PLEASE.
WE ALSO HEARD QUITE A BIT ABOUT
BUSINESS EMAIL COMPROMISE IN G.
EMAIL HAS VERY SPECIFIC
PROTECTION BUILT IN AGAINST THE
TACTICS WE'VE SEEN MOST COMMONLY
USED IN THESE ATTACKS.
SO FOR EXAMPLE HERE'S AN EXAMPLE
OF HOW WE WARN USERS ABOUT EMAIL
THAT TRIES TO SPOOF EMPLOYEE
NAMES THAT MAY BE IN THEIR
DIRECTORY OR THAT COMES FROM AN
ADDRESS THAT LOOKS SIMILAR TO A
CUSTOMER'S OWN ADDRESS VERY
SPECIFIC.
PROTECTIONS THEY DEAL WITH THESE
TACTICS THAT WE'RE SEEING.
WE ALSO AUTOMATICALLY FLAG
EMAILS FROM UNTRUSTED CENTERS
THAT MAY HAVE NOT SENT EMAIL TO
A USER BEFORE THAT MAY INDICATE --
MALICIOUS ACTIVITY WE SCANNED
IMAGES FOR FISHING INDICATORS
AND WE EXPAND SOME OF THE
SHORTENED EMAIL ADDRESSES ARE
YOU ARE A ARE ELSE TO UNCOVER
MALICIOUS LINKS.
WITH THE PROTECTIONS THAT WE
HAVE IN PLACE MORE THAN NINETY
NINE POINT 9% OF BUSINESS EMAIL
COMPROMISE SCENARIOS ARE EITHER
AUTOMATICALLY MOVED TO THE SPAM
FOLDER OR FLAG WITH WARNINGS TO
USERS IN THIS CAN HAVE A VERY
SIGNIFICANT EFFECT.
IN MITIGATING THOSE TYPE OF
ATTACKS.
NEXT SLIDE PLEASE.
THE LAST LINE OF DEFENSE AGAINST
PHISHING ATTACKS IS STOPPING
ATTACKERS IF AND WHEN THEY
MANAGED TO STEAL A PASSWORD.
NOW SOME OF THIS CAN BE DONE BY
SERVICE PROVIDERS FOR EXAMPLE
GOOGLE CHALLENGES MORE THAN ONE
MILLION SIGN IN ATTEMPTS EVERY
DAY WE'RE AN ATTACKER HAS THE
USERS PASSWORD.
BUT WERE OTHER FACTORS MAY BE
SUSPICIOUS OR UNEXPECTED WE ASK
THEM FOR ADDITIONAL INFORMATION
BEFORE THEY LOG IN SO THE MORE
WE CAN DO THE LESS BUSINESSES
NEED TO DO WE CONTINUE TO
ADVANCE OUR CAPABILITIES IN THIS
AREA.
BUT AS WE'VE HEARD FROM OTHER
PANELISTS TODAY THE OTHER
DEFENSE AGAINST OWN PASSWORD IS
ROUTE TO REQUIRE SOMETHING ELSE
IN ADDITION TO THAT USER NAME
AND PASSWORD TO LOG IN.
THIS IS KNOWN AS WE HEARD AS TWO
FACTOR AUTHENTICATION OR AS AT
GOOGLE WE CALL IT TWO STEP
VERIFICATION.
THIS SECOND STEP CAN BE
SOMETHING LIKE A CODE FROM AN
APPLE ON THE PHONE OR AN APP ON
A PC OR CAN BE A TEXT MESSAGE
THAT IS SENT WHEN THE USER
ATTEMPTS TO SIGN IN.
NOW WHILE THIS IS STRONGER THAN
THE USERNAME AND PASSWORD ALONE
SOPHISTICATED ATTACKERS HAVE
FOUND WAYS TO GET AROUND SOME OF
THESE TWO STEP VERIFICATION
METHODS.
AND USERS ALSO DON'T LIKE THE
ADDITIONAL FRICTION THIS THIS
CREATES IN LOGGING IN SO THEY
OFTEN LOOK TO TURN THIS OFFER
CIRCUMVENT IT.
AT GOOGLE WE PIONEERED THE USE
OF A TWO STEP VERIFICATION
METHOD CALLED SECURITY KEYS VERY
SIMPLE -- THAT IS HIGHLY
RESISTANT TO THESE TYPE OF
ATTACKS ALL THE USER HAS TO DO
IS INSERT -- A HEART A SMALL
HARDWARE KEY AND TAP WHEN THEY
ARE ASKED TO LOG IN SO.
IN THIS WEEK WE INTRODUCED A
VERSION OF THIS KEY THAT IS
ACTUALLY BUILT INTO MOST MODERN
ANDROID PHONES THAT MAKES THIS
POWERFUL TECHNOLOGY TO PROTECT
ACCOUNTS AVAILABLE TO ALMOST A
BILLION USERS.
THERE'S A RANGE OF OPTIONS THAT
CAN FIT MOST ORGANIZATIONS WE
SAY THAT SECURITY KEYS ARE EASY
TO DEPLOY.
EASY TO USE BUT VERY HARD ON
FISHER'S.
IN AGAIN TWO STEP VERIFICATION
IS ESPECIALLY IMPORTANT TO PUT
IN PLACE FOR WHAT WE CALL HIGH
VALUES THIS WILL LIKELY BE THE
TARGET.
OF THE SCAMS THAT IN CRIMINAL
ACTIVITY THAT WE HEARD ABOUT
AGAIN EXECUTIVES EMPLOYEES IN
FINANCE FUNCTIONS OR IT
ADMINISTRATORS.
NEXT SLIDE PLEASE.
THE FINAL TECHNOLOGY
RECOMMENDATION THAT I WANT TO
SPEAK ABOUT INVOLVED SOLUTIONS
THAT CAN STOP SENSITIVE DATA
FROM LEAVING AN ORGANIZATION
SYSTEMS.
THIS TAPE THIS TECHNOLOGY IS
CALLED DATA LOSS PREVENTION OR
DLP.
IT CAN DETECT SENSITIVE DATA
SUCH AS SOCIAL SECURITY NUMBERS
CREDIT CARD NUMBERS ACCOUNT
DETAILS HEALTHCARE IDENTIFIERS
IN OTHER PERSONALLY IDENTIFIABLE
INFORMATION.
GOOGLE'S OWN SOLUTION -- IF FOR
THIS TECHNOLOGY DETECTS MORE
THAN NINETY DIFFERENT SENSITIVE
DATA TYPES AUTOMATICALLY AND CAN
BLOCK OR WARN USERS AND YOU CAN
SEE EXAMPLES OF THIS.
WHEN THAT INFORMATION IS BEING
SENT OVER EMAIL OR SHARED IN A
DOCUMENT?
THIS POWERFUL TECHNOLOGIES BUILT
INTO GOOGLE'S EMAIL AND
COLLABORATION PRODUCTS.
DEAL P. CAN STOP INTENTIONALLY
MALICIOUS ACTIVITY SUCH AS THAT
IS BEING DRIVEN BY BAD ACTORS
BUT WE'RE WE SEE THE MOST VALUE --
ESPECIALLY FOR SMALL BUSINESSES
ISN'T HELPING STOP INADVERTENT
DISCLOSURES OF DATA MISTAKES ARE
SITUATIONS WHERE USER MIGHT NOT
EVEN BE AWARE THAT THEY'RE
HANDLING THIS TYPE OF DATA OR
SHARING IT OUT.
MANY DATA BREACHES THAT WE SEE
ARE THE RESULT OF UNINTENDED --
ON INTO UNINTENTIONAL DISCLOSURE
IN THIS TECHNOLOGIES
PARTICULARLY USEFUL IN
ADDRESSING THE SITUATIONS --
NEXT SLIDE PLEASE.
SO THE LAST POINT I WANT TO MAKE
IS THAT THE SOLUTIONS I SPOKE
ABOUT AND PRIORITIZED ARE
FOCUSED ON STOPPING THREATS THAT
PRIMARILY TARGET PEOPLE AND WE
HEARD THIS POINT.
ME VERY STRONGLY IN OUR LAST
PANEL CYBER CRIMINALS KNOWS THE
USERS NOT THE TECHNOLOGY
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT THEY'RE THAT
THEY'RE USING A TAKE ADVANTAGE
OF OUR OFTEN THE EASIEST TARGETS.
SO BUSINESSES LARGE AND SMALL
NEED TO EDUCATE THEIR EMPLOYEES
AND MAKE SECURITY A BUSINESS
PRIORITY THEY MUST HELP UNDER
USERS UNDERSTAND THAT THEY ARE
THE FRONTLINE OF DEFENSE. FOR
THEIR BUSINESS AND THEIR ACTIONS
MAKE A DIFFERENCE WE CAN'T
STIGMATIZE THEM AS VICTIMS WHEN
BAD THINGS HAPPEN THAT'S VERY
YOU KNOW A BAD PRACTICE.
SO TO CONCLUDE.
SMALL BUSINESS YOU SHOULD FOCUS
ON ADDRESSING EMAIL BORNE
THREATS.
PROVIDING ADDITIONAL PROTECTION
FOR THE HIGH VALUE USERS THREE
TWO STEP VERIFICATION AND
MINIMIZING UNINTENDED DISCLOSURE
OF SENSITIVE DATA.
WITH THE HELP OF AFFECTED AND
POWERFUL CLOUD BASED TOOLS THAT
ARE COST EFFECTIVE.
EASY TO IMPLEMENTING USE SMALL
BUSINESSES CAN BECOME MORE
RESILIENT TO CYBER THREATS.
FOCUS ON THEIR CORE BUSINESS
RATHER BECOMING SECURITY EXPERTS
AND PROSPER AND GROW.
WE WANT TO THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK AND SHARE
OUR POINT OF VIEW ARE IMPORTANT
TOPIC AND WE'LL HANDLE QUESTIONS
AS WE DECIDE.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU AND AND
AGAIN A A GREAT PANEL AND I
APPRECIATE YOU TALKING FAST
BECAUSE YOU KNOW WE WERE.
A LITTLE BIT.
SHORT ON TIME BUT SINCE WE HAVE
THE LUXURY OF A COUPLE OF
QUESTIONS I DO HAVE -- FOR BOTH
OF YOU JUST SOME QUICK QUESTIONS
A THE WHAT WE'VE BEEN TALKING SO
MUCH ABOUT TO STEP OF
AUTHORIZATION ON G. MAIL OR
VERIFICATION AND VIA TEXT
MESSAGE NOW YOU MENTIONED THAT
THAT'S NOT A 100%.
SECURITY MORE OF HOW IS IT THAT
THE HACKERS ARE GETTING AROUND
THAT.
YEAH SO -- IN THE CASE THAT THEY
ARE ABLE TO GET AROUND SOME OF
THE FORMS OF TWO STEP
VERIFICATION.
COMMONLY WHAT WILL HAPPEN IS
THAT IT REVIEW RELYING ON AN APP
THAT IS PRESENT ON A PHONE OR
SOMETHING IS SENT VIA TEXT
MESSAGE AND SO IF THERE IS
MALWARE ALREADY ON THE PHONE IT
CAN INTERCEPT THAT CODE.
AND SEND IN THAT CODE AHEAD VERY
SIMILAR TO WHAT WE HEARD ABOUT
SOME OF THE THE ESCROW SKIM SO
THEY CAN THEY CAN DO THAT AND
CAPTURE THAT.
WE'VE ALSO SEEN IN VERY HIGH
VALUE CASES IN AGAIN WITH
SOMETHING HIGH DOLLAR VALUE
THINGS WITH CRYPTO CURRENCY OR
THINGS AROUND ESCROW THEY WILL
ACTUALLY GO TO THE PHONE COMPANY.
AND ASKED TO SWAP YOUR PROBE --
IMPERSONATE A CUSTOMER AND SAY I
NEED TO CHANGE OUT MY SIM CARD
AND SO BY GETTING THAT SIM CARD
THEY CAN ACTUALLY PUT THAT IN A
NEW PHONE AND GET THOSE TEXT
MESSAGES WAS RECENTLY A CASE I
THINK TODAY -- THAT THE FBI
BROUGHT WHERE THEY INDICTED ON
NINE INDIVIDUALS AS A RESULT OF
PERPETRATING SOME OF THE SIM
SWAPPING SCHEMES SO -- AGAIN THE
TECHNOLOGY THAT WE OFFER IN
TERMS OF SECURITY KEYS BECAUSE
IT IS A PHYSICAL HARDWARE DEVICE
AND DOES SOME -- TECHNOLOGY THAT
THAT OUGHT INDICATES BOTH THE
USER AGAIN THE SITE IT'S IMMUNE
TO THOSE DIFFERENT TYPES OF
TECHNOLOGIES BUT AGAIN ANY FORM
OF TWO STEP VERIFICATION IS MUCH
STRONGER THAN A USER NAME AND
PASSWORD ALONE AND WE SHOULDN'T
DISCOURAGE.
THE USE OF ANY OF THOSE FORMS.
AND THE MELHAM THAT WE'RE ON THE
PHONE THAT MIGHT INTERCEPT THE
TEXT MESSAGE WOULD BE THAT YOU
CLICK TO LINK IS SATURATED I
WOULD BE -- IT COULD BE A LINK
THAT WAS CLICKED FOR A USER
DOWNLOADED AN APP -- FROM -- YOU
KNOW A SOURCE THAT IS NOT FOR
EXAMPLE -- THE YOU KNOW THE
PHONE MANUFACTURERS APPS STORE
WERE MOST OF THE APPS THERE ARE
VETTED AND LOOKED OUT FOR
SECURITY PURPOSES WE SEE THIS --
THIS PURPOSE OF AS PRACTICE OF
SIDE LOADING OR BRINGING IN APPS
FROM UNTRUSTED -- UNTRUSTED
SOURCES AND THAT'S A THAT'S A
REALLY COMMON WAY FOR MALWARE TO
GET ON ADVICE OR GET ON THE
PHONE OKAY WE ALWAYS ENCOURAGE
USERS TO DOWNLOAD APPS ONLY FROM.
THE OFFICIAL APP STORES OF THEIR
PHONE MANUFACTURER -- OKAY AND
THEN THE LAST THING YOU
MENTIONED SECURITY PHONE I MEAN
THE SECURITY KIDS FOR ANDROID
PHONES.
NOW FROM G. MAIL YOU DON'T HAVE
ANYTHING FOR IPHONE -- SECURITY
SO NOT NOT AT THIS POINT IN TIME
BUT WE'RE ACTIVELY LOOKING AT
HOW WE CAN EXTEND THIS
TECHNOLOGY CONTENT THAT'S THAT'S
GREAT INFORMATION BECAUSE THAT'S
ONE OF THE WHEN WE DO ALL OUR
CYBER TALKS ONE OF THE FIRST
THINGS WE TALK ABOUT IS.
MAKING SURE THAT THERE'S TWO
SEVEN AUTHENTICATION BUT WE ALSO
WANT TO TRY TO KEEP AHEAD OF OF
SOME OF THE ISSUES THAT ARE
COMING UP.
SO THANK YOU FOR THAT AND THEN I
JUST WANTED TO ASK -- DAVID YOU
HAD MENTIONED ABOUT THE THE AYE
AYE.
WE WERE HEARING A LOT ABOUT THE
THE THE INCREDIBLE POTENTIAL OF
FIVE G. BUT ALSO THE RISKS AND I
I THINK THE RISKS IN THE UNITED
STATES ARE SOMEWHAT LESS THAN
THOSE HAVE WHO HAVE.
CHOSEN TO GO WITH THE CHINESE
TECHNOLOGY.
BUT WHAT WHAT YOU MENTIONED THAT
LEGISLATORS COULD LOOK AT A
LEGISLATION ARE YOU TALKING
ABOUT SPECIFICALLY IN CALIFORNIA
WOULD THAT HAVE TO BE SOMETHING
DONE AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL.
I THINK IT APPLIES ACROSS THE
BOARD MA'AM I THINK -- AS WE
BEGIN TO ADOPT FIVE G..
I THINK TELECOMMUNICATIONS
PROVIDERS NEED TO BE ENCOURAGED
TO FIGURE OUT HOW. TO DESIGN
SECURITY ON THE FRONT END OF
THAT PROCESS AS OPPOSED.
TO KIND OF HOW WE'VE DONE IT FOR
THREE G. AND FOUR G..
YOU KNOW FIGURING OUT HOW WE
TACK ON SECURITY AFTER THE FACT
RIGHT THERE I THINK THIRD I
THINK WHAT POLICY MAKERS CAN
HELP DO.
IS DRIVE YOU KNOW A DEEPER
DISCUSSION INTO HOW SECURITY IS
GOING TO BE IMPACTED BY FIVE G..
NOT NECESSARILY A A SPECIFIC
LEGISLATIVE FIX OR ACTION.
BUT JUST PROMOTING KIND OF THE
CONVERSATION THAT CONSIDER.
AND AND WE HAVE OF LAST YEAR
WITH OUR INTERNET OF THINGS
BUILT.
THAT'S ONE OF THE THINGS WE
TALKED ABOUT IS THAT ALL THESE
FANCY GADGETS THAT WERE.
YOU KNOW THAT OUR OUR OUR OUR
DOOR BILLS AND ARE.
YOU KNOW ALEXA THAT REALLY WE
NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
DESIGNERS ARE THINKING ABOUT
SECURITY FOR SECURITY BY DESIGN
AND SO -- THAT WE WE CERTAINLY
BEEN PREACHING THAT PRIORITY
YEAH FIFTY BILLION OUT TO
DEVICES BY TWENTY TWENTY IT'S OF
VERY IMPORTANT AT SOME BASIC
SECURITY AND THEIR SELF.
AGAIN I WANT TO THANK OUR
PANELISTS ESPECIALLY ARE OUT OF
TOWN PANELISTS LOVE THE THE BUG
BOUNTY DISCUSSION AND AND THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
FOR JOINING US -- HERE TODAY AND
I'VE I KNOW PEOPLE MIGHT HAVE
QUESTIONS A LOT OF THE PANELISTS
ARE STILL AROUND SO I THINK --
HOPEFULLY AFTER AND THEY CAN
INDIVIDUALLY ASK QUESTIONS BUT
AGAIN WANT TO THANK OUR THIRD.
PANEL AND ALL THE REST OF OUR
SPEAKERS TODAY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND THAT IS THE END OF OUR
SELECT COMMITTEE HEARING THANK
YOU